so the indictment against Donald Trump
is so laughably bad that tons of leftist
media Outlets are even coming out being
like uh this doesn't look like it's
gonna hold any water of course
conservative Outlets are calling it as
it is like there's no in there's no real
crime being committed it's beyond the
statute of limitations but even CNN has
said the other day they're like this is
completely underwhelming now we have
vox.com saying is he actually gonna get
convicted of this because there's no
underlying crime Bragg said I'm not
required to present one so there isn't
one I'm just telling you there is
how could that possibly fly this is the
weirdest thing I mean it reeks of
desperation but the craziest thing is
that Democrats are basically just
deciding to what knock the pegs out from
this country to just tear it down a
little bit with these dubious charges or
maybe brag is the Rogue prosecutor who's
embarrassing himself we'll talk about
that plus we got a few other stories so
we got uh RFK Jr is going to run as a
Democrat opposing Joe Biden that will be
interesting and then in North Carolina
you had a demo you have a Democrat who
just switched to the Republican Party
giving them a super majority in the
state and yes the left is losing their
minds because they're concerned now that
child sex changes and abortion will be
completely banned that's right a veto
proof majority in North Carolina so
while everyone's complaining that this
Ultra far left Supreme Court Justice won
in Wisconsin and there's reason to be
upset about it you got to look where the
victories are too and just keep in mind
it's not all negative all the time in
North Carolina Democrat outright said
like yo I'm out I'm a republican now so
that's big we'll see how that develops
so before we get into all that ladies
and gentlemen today's episode of Tim
castero is brought to you by cast Brew
Coffee pre-order your cast brew coffee
today at castbrew.com this is of course
our coffee brand we are launching a
coffee shop currently in design and
construction is underway plus a private
club on the third floor really excited
for that you can go to castbrew.com and
order your rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend available now it will be
delivered by uh it will ship by May 5th
these are pre-orders we just had a
production so of course now we are
sponsoring ourselves with our own coffee
brand
you can see we are we have a a rooster
as our mascot but also head over to
timcast.com click the join us button
become a member and not only will you
get access to the uncensored members
only after show but after you sign up
become a member you can join the Discord
server and if you've been a member for
it's at least six months or you sign up
at the 25 level you will get access to
the VIP chat section of the Discord
where you can submit questions and maybe
even call into the show and talk to us
and our guest live in the uncensored
portion so that's the most exciting
thing we've been doing lately and now
we're going to be launching this new
program where every Friday the sponsor
of the show will be you our members so
we have a new section set up where
members can submit their projects
companies and things they work on and
because the members basically already
sponsor the show we will shout out the
members projects so I that was a really
brilliant idea that came from the
Discord Community very excited for that
don't forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends joining us tonight to
talk about all of this is Dave Smith
what's up good to be back so who are you
what are you doing oh you you know
libertarian Tupac servant of the mises
caucus repping the Ron Paul Revolution
oh all right those are all good things
yeah that's me yeah uh this will be
interesting because it's it's uh
seeing you talk about the indictment and
everything but coming from a Libertarian
perspective it's it's funny how they
often try and just accuse you of being
like a trump supporting conservative
yeah I mean like it's you know I get it
from all angles like that I mean I'm a
sharp critic of Donald Trump but last
time I was on the show me and you talked
a lot about that and we kind of
disagreed about it but I convinced you
of everything and now you agree with me
so yeah no I was I was right well here
I'll tell you something um I was wrong
about because as you guys know I'm right
about almost everything uh but you know
what I was really wrong about I remember
when they first
um uh put the special prosecutor on
Donald Trump when Robert Mueller was
first assigned to him I was just
convinced I knew obviously there was
going to be nothing with a Russian
conspiracy because I knew that was all
made up
um and Libertarians know not to trust
the CIA but I really did think they
would get him for something I was just
like the guy was a real estate developer
in New York City he's got to have some
dirt on him you can't rent an apartment
in New York City without committing at
least a misdemeanor uh I figured they'd
find something and it is amazing that
after all of this time they're still
they still just have to make up a non
uh thanks for hanging out this would be
fun of course and uh maybe maybe
there'll be an announcement later it's
unrelated I have no idea but Diana
Claire's hanging out hi I'm Hannah
Claire brimlow I'm a writer for
timcast.com
how you doing I am philibonti lead
singer of All That Remains
anti-communist and counter-revolutionary
and I am not Ian he's not here but I was
going to say and temporary Ian yeah
temporary hopefully I will come up with
uh some some some 20s if you if you
could do us a favor and randomly
interrupt the conversation with
non-sequiturs and talks of graphene come
up with I can come up with some Ian Ian
you're going to be on talking about
crystals Duty I mean I've got them all
in front of me you know I mean we need
at least four Crystal facts did you have
to like rub them on your oh yeah I could
have brought my jade girl he's rubbing
Ian's Chris on his face I can imagine
Ian's watching going like stop no no
that one though
that one's that's not even what that
Crystal does
Ian's pulling his hair out at home I
apologize
I'm just watching all this go down
anyways uh let's get started guys so
here's the first story from National
Review Bragg's indictment even fails as
an indictment and this is a really great
piece from Andrew McCarthy who's like
what a disgrace it's always possible to
be surprised the indictment brought by
Manhattan's elected Democratic district
attorney Evan Bragg against Trump is
even worse than it imagined and here's
the important part he says he claims
that the 34 counts which warrant 136
years in prison are because Trump was
trying to conceal another crime what is
that other crime we don't know because
Bragg says he doesn't need to present it
it just is that's it
now here now look a lot of people orange
that's the crime well he's like Trump
lied in running for office it's like
about what I don't got to tell you
because it's not required it's not the
point and federal campaign contributions
was a crime and they were like the feds
did not charge him with a crime over
anything you have no jurisdiction here
he's doing it anyway but here's what
gets here's the best part here's the
satisfying icing on the cake vox.com
wrote yesterday the dubious legal Theory
at the heart of the Trump indictment
explained no one knows if Donald Trump
can be prosecuted for the hush money
payment the actual original title of
this article was Will trump actually be
convicted they don't even think so it's
fascinating to see CNN be like uh
there's nothing here no new facts it's
it's what everyone already knew and
their brag is doing it anyway so I gotta
say like okay you know maybe maybe we'll
end up sitting back and what's really
happening is this of a D.A steps
out from a local office and embarrasses
the Democratic party nationally and
Trump is playing the game because he
knows every step of the way it's
humiliating to them yeah it is it's it's
really something to see man and you know
like as I said before even as a sharp
critic of of Donald Trump for other
reasons not like the stupid ones
um but this is just look the guy was
just objectively this is a guy who was
as sitting president framed for treason
like framed for treason by his own deep
State there's a real deal attempted coup
they all knew he was not involved in a
conspiracy with Russia nobody at the CIA
or the FBI actually believe that none of
them believed Carter page was a Russian
agent
the CIA told the FBI that he was an
informant for the CIA and then the FBI
uh said on their fisa Court application
that the CIA corroborated that he had
talked to the Russians but they left out
the part that then he came right back to
the CIA and informed them of this so
this is it is I don't know for sure if
this Sorrows backed uh D.A is like in on
some Grand conspiracy he might be but
there is no question that what Donald
Trump laid out in his speech last night
is exactly right that they've tried at
every single turn to get him for the
most ridiculous things and like probably
like Phil like I'd be fine if they
wanted to get him for any of his real
crimes that he did commit like all
presidents commit like real it
violations of international law illegal
bombing of Syria illegally starving the
people of Yemen fine charge him for that
I'll cheer if you do the problem is that
that would implicate Joe Biden and
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton and George
Bush and Dick Cheney and so they're not
going to do that and so you got to go
after him for this stuff I think they
should uh
I think they should I mean you know they
indicted Trump and it's it's fair game
now so what I said the other day is that
any conservative D.A in Colorado or san
or the San Diego area wherever Abdul
Rahman al-alalaki lived should there's
no statute of limitations on murder so
they could they could indict Barack
Obama for the murder of Abdul Rahman
al-alaki or even Anwar alaki for that
matter who was his father who look he
did he he was radicalized and he swore
allegiance to Al Qaeda but when you're
an American citizen
you have to be charged with a crime and
then you have to be convicted of that
crime you don't get to just say this guy
said he's with them so I murdered him
and and the one that's more damning
about Anwar Lucky in a way even then his
his was his kid 14 at the time 16 16. oh
yeah I think 16. um but the one that's
more damning you know in a sense is that
they admitted that he was the target so
they try to pretend that the kid wasn't
the target but they admit that Anwar
alaki was the target of that strike so
Barack Obama murdered an American
citizen with no charges Barack Obama
murdered an American citizen and he got
no charges and the Deep state turns
their head and all the time I would love
to have you talk with Destiny the Omni
liberal because you know what his
response was when he was here he was
like well he's the president he has
great deference when it comes to war and
I was like not telling Americans in
countries we are not at war with by what
standard does he have this like like
what are you talking about according to
the United States uh Constitution
since World War II right so all these
military authorizations are completely
unconstitutional and then there's also
international law which says you can't
just bomb Sovereign countries can we
just go back a second because you said
something I think was important
isn't it amazing that the Deep State and
the Democrats framed our democratically
elected president as a traitor and
foreign agent they they framed him as
this and it's like that is the normal
course of action now for this country
that that's crazy well I mean look they
framed a sitting president well say I
mean they also blew one's brains out on
National Television so it's not like
well talking about the president Carlson
comes out and he's like didn't he
basically come out and say JFK was
assassinated by the CIA or whatever yeah
he said a guy
um uh who you know an anonymous source
who had seen firsthand all the redacted
uh documents basically confirmed it to
him now do with that what you will but
there's a I mean you could go down that
rabbit hole there's a lot there I'll
also say the Nixon thing really stinks
if you look into it like what was it I
think uh two of the four people who
broke into Watergate were like CIA
connected just saying there's a lot of
shady stuff in the past but what's
really interesting about Donald Trump is
that Donald Trump although I will
criticize him for not following through
with a lot of his rhetoric that was
pretty good on some of this stuff Donald
Trump was the first presidential
candidate or I should say the first
successful presidential candidate who
won in any of our lifetime times who ran
unapologetically in opposition to the
Deep State yeah I mean like he ran
saying that like we were lied into war
in Iraq saying that Obama created Isis
saying all of these things that were
kind of true I mean Obama certainly
funded Isis
um and and so he made enemies of the
deep state in a way that none of these
other presidents have when I remember
watching the uh debates when Trump told
uh who did he tell Jeb Bush or whatever
when he was like your brother lied I
said to war or something like that South
Carolina I was like
whoa it was pretty pretty unreal that
moment of standing in front of South
Carolina Republicans at the primary
debate and telling the whole crowd that
the last Republican president not like
led us into a bad war or something like
that lied us into a war where a million
people died like basically saying he he
should be you know like arrested or
whatever and I remember that day all the
pundits were like well he blew it yeah I
mean he really looked that ain't gonna
play in South Carolina and the next day
was the South Carolina primary Donald
Trump took 60 percent of the vote and
the other 11 split the 40 amongst
themselves wow it's so amazing yeah well
so uh so you're you're now the a a Maga
Trump supporter all the way now I hear I
I said he should be convicted for war
crimes I'm just saying get all of them
but you shouldn't be convicted for
paying off a hooker and not itemizing it
on his taxes amazing that's what it is
yeah
they're they're they're they're
claiming that uh this is this is what's
funny
uh is imagine you you uh Dave have a
carpenter buddy who is uh remodeling
your garage and it's an attached to
garage so you know you want to put like
a loft and second floor of it or
something and uh he goes to the store
and he buys burglars tools and he Robs a
jewelry store and then uh he sends you a
bill for the construction in your garage
and it just itemized as construction and
you pay it and then one day the feds
come to your house and say you are
actually buying in burglars tools and
you're like what what you've got a
payment here that went right to him
you're paying him every month and you
were like yeah he's a carpenter in my
garage like my buddy bought Burger
stools that's the Trump indictment
Michael Cohen according to his own
lawyers paid Stormy Daniels of his own
volition with no reimbursement out of
his own pocket Donald Trump was paying
legal bills to Michael Cohen and they
just decided Bragg says he was probably
reimbursing him we just say that and
it's even weaker than than uh your
analogy because there's no actual crime
committed to it like it's not a crime to
pay someone to not talk about something
like to come to an agreement with
someone if I give you this money you
won't talk about it there's no crime and
it's not a campaign Finance right
violation the reason why he hasn't been
tried federally is because there's
already president for this with John
Edwards or they tried to say that oh you
paying off your side piece is a campaign
Finance violation the problem is that
the logic of that is like oh it would
have hurt your campaign so therefore
it's a campaign Finance you know or a
campaign but the the problem with that
is that there's also lots of other
non-campaign related reasons why you
might want to like he might just not
want his wife to find out right and you
can't say you can't say anything that
would make you look bad is a campaign
expense or any otherwise anything that
makes you look good should be a campaign
expense too right you should be able to
charge your campaign for a new
convertible because you're like I look
good when I drive this the whole thing
it makes most sense yeah did you watch
album bags uh press conference you got
pressed by these reporters saying you
know your predecessor wouldn't prosecute
this this has been thrown out a couple
different times why are you moving
forward with it and he didn't really
have any answer to that he was just like
well
uh he's committed crimes 34 of them I
guess like there was no explanation
because there's not one yeah it was it
was asked by a reporter in order for
this to be elevated to a felony there
has to be an underlying crime what is
that crime and why didn't you include it
he goes the law does not require me to
which is not true the law that he is
invoking says you can't that it's a
crime to um to lie on your business
records in service of another crime so
there it has to be connected to another
crime he's just like trying to play this
he's arguing it is but it doesn't say
there that I have to tell you what that
crime is right right so that I mean it's
just so freaking absurd and then the
sixth amendment basically says we have a
right to as I confront our accusers and
understand the charges and a speedy
trial and all that Jess so uh not now
the Bragg's courtroom he says None
that's why that's why I've just been
saying like
I mean I should have been saying this
years ago when they as you pointed out
framed our democratically elected
president as a foreign agent and and
traitor to this country uh perhaps I
should have been saying the country
ended in 2016. yeah I mean I'd go 1913
but sure wherever you want to start it
creation of the Federal Reserve uh but I
um I'll say that it's even to me who's
like you know I'm pretty against this
entire establishment against every inch
of the U.S federal government I thought
I was I was surprised that they crossed
the line once he was President I thought
it was a crazy line to cross to frame
the presidential candidate Donald Trump
for treason but when they actually you
had them doing it to the sitting
president uh even to me I was like wow
they're actually gonna do this to this
guy and look they didn't they they
didn't remove him from office they
floated around that idea and in fact um
Andrew McCabe who I believe was the
number three at the justice department
he talked about this in his 60s Minutes
interview where he says before they they
suck Robert Mueller on Donald Trump they
all in the Department of Justice in the
FBI debated invoking the 25th Amendment
they were like maybe we could just
remove he like says this you can go find
his words on camera says that they
thought about well we could just remove
him but instead we'll just stick this uh
special prosecutor on him and that and
so they didn't they didn't remove him
but they did box him in and they box at
what Donald Trump ran on in 2016 was
that we should have detaunt with Russia
that we should get along with Russia we
should stop trying to overthrow Bashar
al-assad and Syria we should work with
Russia to fight Isis there because we
both have a mutual interest there and
why not get along with Russia why not
move in this direction of being friends
and man so because they were accusing
him of being a Russian agent every day
on TV he could never make a deal with
Russia because then that would have been
seen as like oh look proof he clearly is
a Russian agent so then he Donald Trump
because he's
not Ron Paul and not the great president
he was supposed to be uh he went out of
his way to prove how anti-russia he was
so he goes I'm not a Russian agent I'll
show you right now I'll tear up the IMF
treaty I'll draw I'll send weapons into
Ukraine I'll do everything to show you
how much of a hawk I am on Russia so
they it actually did work in a sense
where they boxed him into taking the
wrong position and man if he had been
able to do what he was running on we
wouldn't be in the disaster in Ukraine
we are today there'd be a hundred
thousand people who would still have
their lives
I agree yeah what do you think about uh
the upcoming election you're gonna
you're gonna vote Trump no
uh you know do you think you'll vote
libertarian I think there's a strong
chance there's a strong chance that I
could vote Liberty we got to see who uh
the candidate is
so I mean there's so many great options
I mean yeah that guy that guy gets up
there I'm obviously he's running a
Libertarian oh wow running around his
living room in his boxers Democrat
though I think he runs he runs as a
Democrat no he's probably bragging down
the libertarian party for the past no
those those days are over it's a new
libertarian party now are you guys
Fielding then I want to know well we've
got a lot of great candidates that's
very non-specific I'll answer Alvin
Bragg that's the most specific I can
give you I don't have to give you a
crime I don't need to give you anything
um but I will say no I wouldn't I'm I'm
interested I I will say that Donald
Trump's rhetoric over the last say
couple months has been the best he's
been since at least 2016. yeah the stuff
he's been saying on the Ukraine war has
been spot on now that's a big difference
between me actually trusting him he said
some good things in 2016 and then he's
putting John Bolton as his National
Security advisor so that's it's one
thing to say it but I will say ma'am the
other day uh when he he had that uh
Speech or whatever where he said he was
like the number one enemy for America is
not Russia the number one enemy is and I
was just so sure he was going to say
China and I was already rolling my eyes
I was like preemptively rolling my eyes
at him saying China and then he went the
number one enemy is the Deep State and
Washington DC and all of this and I just
I felt myself standing to clap like I
thought the innocent I fought it but I
felt myself standing in clap for him so
there's a lot better to see him talking
like this than talking about how he
saved a million people's lives because
they had he invented the vaccine or
whatever but you know you know that he's
like he's definitely gonna be like there
after me so he's gonna sit there and
attack the Deep State and if he wants to
go after the bureaucracy more like for
this entire time that he's running more
power to him attack them show you show
as much show show you know as much of
the bad stuff they do make it you know
shines much light as you can you know
um I just you know he had the chance to
do something about it and he didn't I
just think he has some fire back right
now like when he announced in November I
didn't feel it the way that you know
obviously the iconic escalator moment
and you know with East Palestine with
some of his rhetoric it seems like he
has got his momentum back in a way that
is truly terrifying to other candidates
you can't really compete with Donald
Trump when he is ready to spar with you
and it's really mate put him in a
fighting position of late yeah well look
and this fuels some conspiracy theories
uh too which I I don't know if there's
any truth to any of them but there is no
question to me that it really helps
Donald Trump with his base when they
raid his home in Mar-A-Lago and when
they bring these nonsense charges to him
because it does again make him kind of
like it gives you this narrative that of
course as we were saying is based off a
lot of truth that he has been completely
targeted but like he won the election in
2016 and he never got a chance to
actually be president of the United
States let me pull up this story from
the hill GOP rep Thomas Massey endorses
DeSantis for 2024. that's it that's the
story he said America needs a leader who
is decisive respects the Constitution
understands policy puts Family First and
leads by inspiring that's why I'm
endorsing Ron DeSantis for president if
we make the right choices America's best
days are in front of us let's pick a
proven energetic leader who can get us
there he continued let's choose Rhonda
Santos for president that means that
Donald Trump is going to knock
representative Thomas Massey down to a
fifth rate well so uh I I've talked Ad
nauseam about my views on DeSantis I
think he's fantastic I really do think
he's done a great job in Florida I don't
know if I would uh at this point right
now vote for him over Trump I'm curious
Dave what you think about Massey's
endorsement and DeSantis well I mean
look I you know I'm not exactly sure
first off Thomas Massey is the best
Congressman in the country so just yeah
I give him a lot of credit and look
Thomas Massey was the one who stood up
in real time while the covid emergency
was going on and said this is insane to
just be giving away two trillion dollars
in corporate bailouts with no type of
like vote no audit of what's going on
and he was completely demonized by by
Donald Trump at the time Donald Trump
really sent all of his sycophants after
Massey which is a horrible thing to do
Messi was 100 right this is what create
not only like really created so much of
the instability we have today but so
much of the price inflation that people
have been suffering under for the last
couple years was due to these monstrous
spending bills in 2020. so I also
understand why Massey maybe isn't the
biggest fan of Donald Trump I was with
Trump on that back during the uh the
shutdowns but I think it's fair to say
that hindsight is 2020 and I think you
know my view of it back then was
there's videos of people collapsing in
the street we don't know a whole lot
maybe we just need to stem the bleed of
the economic you know problems now and
then try and figure out what's what's
going on
looking back on all of it yeah I think
Thomas Massey was completely right well
that's the best I can do that's fair
enough um I I think that the the thing
is like if you understand the nature of
how the federal government like like
bills like this work you just know it's
just it's not as if there's ever any
real like oh the people are hurting so
we need Aid it's just a race of
lobbyists everyone getting their little
special thing in there and then you're
lucky if the American people get like
some crumbs on it but anyway but I'll
just say that I do think look it's hard
it's hard to deny that even though he
wasn't very good at the very beginning
that what DeSantis did in Florida for uh
for coved was just so much better than
almost every other governor in the
country I guess Christy gnome is the
exception to that I think she never had
any mandates or lockdowns or anything
but South Dakota is not Florida and
Florida is a much bigger state with an
old population and he really put all of
his chips in at a very dangerous time on
We're not gonna go to Tyrion here in
Florida and it paid off and so I
understand where there's there's a
reason why he flipped a purple State
into a 20-point red State you know I
mean it's it's you you have to
acknowledge that and the mass Exodus
from these blue States into Florida
because of his leadership so the
question then becomes DeSantis or Trump
now obviously I know you know you're
probably a more libertarian guy but
based like let's let's isolate this to
the GOP Primary who do you think would
be better for the Republicans
well for the Republicans and just it's
real clear to presence it's not again
because I was trying to say this last
time I was on the show it's not like I'm
saying like the it's like well the I'm
not making the perfect the enemy of the
good I'm not saying like I understand
Republicans both uh Trump or DeSantis
would be much better than Joe Biden in a
lot of ways my thing is that I think
America is going to die like I think
this is a patient who's bleeding out and
you're like well a Band-Aid is better
than not a Band-Aid and I'm like no he
will still die we need like a a like a
revolutionary moment here to drastically
cut the the size of the scope of
government I will say for uh from the
repo what you asked me from the
Republican perspective as of right now I
gotta say I just don't I don't really
see any metric by which DeSantis is
better for the Republicans Donald Trump
has as I've known when I've that like
argued with you about my criticisms of
Donald Trump I had a debate with uh
sticks about this and I've heard back
from lot of the Trump supporters and I
don't even mean this is a knock on them
but there is a bit of a uh Cult of
Personality going on there they if
you're if DeSantis goes to war with
Donald Trump which it'll have to be in
order for him to like challenge him for
the nomination there I don't think
Trump's people will fall in line with
DeSantis I think they're Trump or bust
and I think the only guy the Republican
the Republicans have who can actually
put that Coalition together whether
that's enough to win I don't know but I
think it's Trump there's probably a lot
of moderates who would vote for DeSantis
but wouldn't vote for Trump there's a
lot of people
will not vote for Trump yeah there might
there might be some I mean that's
probably true you know the other thing
DeSantis is such a big question mark on
his foreign policy and he was really bad
as a congressman on this issue well
let's celebrate on that because I've
heard people say he was good oh no I
mean he well good if you're like you
know like good if you think like George
W bush had great foreign policy then
sure but no he was a he was a complete
hawk in every sense of the word he was
uh he was like on board with every one
of the military like uh actions that he
could have been while he was in Congress
now that doesn't matter so much when
you're governor of Florida and when
you're governor of Florida your covid
policy is like a hell of a lot more
important than where you stand on the
wars but when you're the president of
the United States the most important
thing is where you stand on the wars
that's the one area where you're like
the dictator and so that's that's a big
deal so about a year ago in reference to
your Cult of Personality thing with
people who have argued about a year ago
I was I was totally on board for
DeSantis and I said you know Trump's
whining and he won't shut up about 2020
and I'm not interested that was rough to
listen to too and so I'm just like and
then here's the scientist who's coming
and clean up cleaning up all these
Messes in in Florida and doing a great
job now over the past several months
I've seen something else Donald Trump
has cleaned up his messaging he's come
out he's talked about the war machine
he's talked about the Deep State the
economy he's made these videos where
he's like my policy will be to do this
thing and I'm like these are good he
shows up in East Palestine he buys
everything McDonald's which was human
and endearing and I really liked it but
more importantly he's gotten back to the
I will crush the Deep State and Execute
Order schedule F and Ron DeSantis to me
when this is important because this was
a this is a critical moment for me
when they said they wanted to indict
Trump and Ron DeSantis two times said
I'm not getting involved in this I was
like I can't vote for that guy I think
he's great I think he's great if I was
in Florida I'd vote for him for governor
as president the guy whose attitude is I
don't look at me I'm not getting
involved is like are you kidding me dude
we need Donald Trump to go in and fire
everyone and DeSantis showed me right
there he's more likely to be the guy who
goes in and says how can we work
together yeah the FBI needs to be
reformed or something like that yeah
Trump's going to be like I want revenge
well he might I mean that that very
likely might be the case although Donald
Trump has been wronged by people and
then worked with them and and endorsed
and supported or even appointed them
before so I don't know I'm not that
confident I will say what really
bothered me with the Ron DeSantis thing
was that he walked back the somewhat
good comments he had made about the war
in Ukraine
um I think there's it's an interesting
Dynamic here where you have say like the
Republican Party Republican
establishment is completely on board
with this with this war this proxy war
of choice on the border of the country
with the biggest nuclear Arsenal in the
history of the world the most insane
policy imaginable and you got Mitch
McConnell is wearing like a Ukraine
lapel pen Mitch McConnell said the
number one issue the number one priority
as this country is crumbling is that we
keep supporting Ukraine uh and so it was
kind of interesting to see now Donald
Trump's coming out and saying telling
the truth which is that this is we
should just be negotiating toward peace
right now this is insane that we're
fighting this proxy war
um DeSantis kind of came out and kind of
said like well I don't know if it's
exactly a vital that we do this and then
seem to kind of walk those comments back
to me if there's gonna be one compelling
case to vote for anybody
uh it would be who is going to end this
insanity this game of brinksmanship that
has brought us closer to nuclear war
than at any point at least since the
Cuban Missile Crisis the libertarian
party
should any one of their potential
candidates just put it that way very
very vaguely uh should any one of their
candidates become the president do you
think they will execute schedule F
schedule F we have firing all the
bureaucrats I I think that yes I mean
look
so unless you have look a lot of things
have to happen in order for that to
happen but let's say if the libertarian
candidate for president wins the
presidency then there has already been a
major shift in this country right like
something huge has happened where a
whole bunch of people have gone hey
we're going to completely rethink the
way we think about politics right now
and we like this guy who's talking about
giving us more of a free country so
there would be there would be a
tremendous mandate behind that person
unlike any Republican or Democrat could
have if they had one because so many
people are just voting for their party
and so yeah now I would say
um of course that's what we would do
you'd probably want to do it in a
strategically smart way you know I would
be a little bit concerned about I
wouldn't take any convertible rides
through Dallas the day after I uh gave
that order can I say I I want to make a
request to the people who are listening
because I don't have the means to do
this but could somebody take the scene
from Star Wars when the emperor says
that order you know Execute Order 66 and
just make it Trump in a cloak and use
the 11 Labs AI voice deep fake
technology to make Trump say execute and
schedule F and then just show a whole
bunch of bureaucrats being like let out
of offices with empty boxes and stuff
like that well it'll be well it plays
the very serious medic
I just the problem with Trump is at
least say the first time he was
President I never saw anything out of
them that convinced me that he would
actually follow through with something
that bold and every time he flirted
around with doing something really bold
he walked it back he oh they whoever got
in the room with him whatever they
convinced them or lied to him or
threatened him or whatever it was he
always said he hired the absolute best
guy that you should hire who should have
been his defense secretary from day one
but he hired Colonel Douglas McGregor uh
to come in and draw up the plans to end
these wars and he hired him after he
lost the election to Joe Biden so they
had just this little lame duck period to
work with Colonel Douglas McGregor draws
up the the um the order to end the war
in Afghanistan and Syria and pull all
troops out Donald Trump signs it and the
next day he rescinded the offer hey it
rescinded the order excuse me now I
don't know who got in the room with them
I don't know she's listening to his
idiot uh friend Lindsey Graham or he's
listening to his idiot son-in-law I
don't know who it was but one way or the
other that's what happened and Donald
Trump would say the right things about
like sometimes on covid but he'd never
really do it and I also I'll also just
never forgive him for uh for keeping
fauci on the job through all of 2020.
mocking Sweden for not locking down you
know like it was I just like the
funniest thing ever to me would be if
like there's a dramatic political shift
in the next year where people are like
you know moderate say I just don't want
to vote for Trump then Along Comes This
more uh personable relatable libertarian
candidate who's preaching all of these
things and then the moment that
libertarian gets in office he starts
bombing a bunch of foreign countries
whoa she goes guys and then like people
like like Phil's like dude what are you
doing like you made all these promises I
go hey dude you want to be the head of
Raytheon
I can get you a pretty sweet gig I go I
don't know it just looks a lot different
from the inside than it was from the
outside it Phil's on the show and he's
like I can't believe we are betrayed by
this guy but I'm gonna be sitting down
and talk with some sense into him and
then the next day it's like he's wearing
a suit and he was like you are all wrong
about the war and you hate America
yeah Phil did you always have Diamond
contact lens you know I wouldn't talk
about a new job but there would be signs
there would be signs let's uh let's jump
to this story because this one's
interesting we're from uh the New York
Intelligencer New York Magnum the
mystery of North Carolina's Democratic
Defector is that that that's that's it
huh look at this citizen Free Press
North Carolina Democrat Trisha cotham is
now a republican here's the the clip
let's see what she has to say is the the
audio right should be
it's muted on the video nope there's
just no sound coming through
let's try reloading
oh or there's no sound in the video
that can't be right I mean are you sure
what I'm saying here it should be a good
yeah I guess there's no sound in the
video just play it I'll lip read okay
Democrats are totally whack
she said the modern day Democratic party
has become unrecognizable to me if you
don't do exactly what the Democrats want
you to do they will try to bully you
they will try to cast you aside maybe I
can just do this maybe this will play
properly
there is no sound coming out of this
thing hmm
yeah I don't know I don't know we should
be here I blame I blame the winner I
like I find it pretty funny like you
said anyway she quit there you go yeah
they said they're big concerns is that
there's going to be abortion
restrictions and restrictions on uh
trans and kids child sex changes which
is just such a funny thing to just be
like all right no more murdering babies
and you're like we can still chemically
castrate them though in a few years
right like nope not either like look we
can't do anything
the Republicans won't let us do anything
but uh here's what I said about it
because they got that in Wisconsin they
elected that uh Supreme Court uh justice
or whatever judge in Wisconsin and uh I
guess the issue was gen Z in abortion
and so I just tweeted I was like look
man I've never been this like hardcore
staunch pro-life dude I think there
should be some restrictions on abortion
I think abortion is is bad in most
circumstances there's questions I have
from a Libertarian perspective but also
from a practical perspective the end
result of democrat policy is the end of
democrat policy in 20 years there will
be substantially more conservative kids
if conservatives right now have 10 kids
per family 10 of them in 20 years you
will have 10 times the voting base I'm
not even as it's not well five times
because you got man and a woman you know
they have 10 kids so that's two and you
get five so uh I recommend it that's the
path to Victory I'll never understand
why Democrats decided that they were
going to campaign on abortion is birth
control and therefore an attack on uh
abortion is an attack on birth control
like they should have been like cool we
lost abortion so now let's really push
to have you know the pill or condoms or
whatever they're trying to get to young
people like they could have used this as
a moment to win something back you took
you took abortions away and so if you
want to prevent us from needing
abortions you should give us birth
control but instead they open them
together I mean they sell it as one
package they sell it as abortion is a
form of birth control and so therefore
we have to regulate them the same way
well there's something interesting
however you feel about abortion
um like whether you're pro-life or
pro-choice or whatever somewhere in
between there's something interesting
about it abortion in a lot of ways kind
of underwrites the entire cultural order
that modern day liberalism is built off
of
um anything like the idea of like there
there's no difference between the Sexes
or their like hook up culture kind of
like any of this like rejection of
traditional uh you know religious and
cultural values all doesn't work if you
don't have access to abortion because as
soon as you don't have access to
abortion it becomes very clear where men
and women are different it becomes very
clear what the risks of uh promiscuity
is like there's just no like separating
yourself from it and it kind of is This
force that pushes you back toward more
of a traditional lifestyle if you are if
you getting drunk and having sex with
some random person can result in what
you having to carry this baby to term
like that is going to be a that is going
to be a game changer in kind of like the
post 60s sexual Revolution interactions
between men and women and so I think
there's something where it's more than
just they believe like you have a right
to an abortion it's something where like
they understand that this is
fundamentally foundational to to all of
their the the cultural revolution of the
60s continuing because we'll revert
right back to traditional Norms very
quickly if you don't have this which is
also part of the reason why I oppose it
I don't think that we I don't think that
you could you could prevent the the
reversion to traditional Norms without
it like if you can't have you know if
you can't have the basically the the
type of promiscuous sex with no
ramifications then the entire
Progressive order falls apart yeah
everything from feminism queer Theory
everything just just all falls apart
yeah and and like statism especially the
most ugly forms of it like big powerful
governments always make the family the
community the church the enemy because
these are the things that guard again
they're like Hedges on state power they
don't want you to have a strong family
unit because then you're much less
likely to be dependent on the state they
don't want you to be like very connected
to your community and your church and
because then you don't view Brown Barack
Obama is a God because he's just a man
you know at risk of sounding like a red
pill like one of those manosphere dudes
they don't want dudes that are capable
of taking care of their house and taking
care of their family and stuff because
if the more yeah what's up with those
dudes by the way by the way I I agree
with the point you just made but it's
like what is up with all these podcasts
blowing up where it's like some guy
winning a debate with like five chicks
dressed for the club
I just
I just get like relationships and stuff
are good and he's like really well do
you know the stats on that you're like
wow you owned this 20 year old chick in
a mini skirt I don't understand that hey
married like why are we taking you're
talking specifically about the whatever
podcast no I I think I've seen a few of
them I don't know
there's some some of them are good Clips
I'm just the algorithm keeps showing
them to me and I do agree with you
listen the problem is that it's like
that if you actually want relationship
advice about what's going to lead to
like a healthy stable marriage from
people who are in healthy stable
marriages this is what I've always
wondered about have you ever heard of I
don't remember what it's called but like
maybe you should talk about this uh this
therapist Esther Farrell who's really
big and she has some interesting
insights she's a couples counselor but
she's been divorced multiple times and
so every once in a while like someone
will be like you should listen to this
episode it's really good and like I want
to be appreciative of a diverse
worldview right but I don't want to take
marriage advice from someone who is not
married I feel like that's who's been
divorced several times yeah you know
what I mean I feel like it's both ends
of the book like I've never been married
so therefore I'm probably not the best
to hand out marriage advice I like
marriage I'm for it but I also think I
may be as good as the person who's been
divorced
they have this viral clip from a long
time ago of me where I mentioned
something about like modern feminists
make it impossible to date or something
and like of course I'm in a relationship
and been for for a while and like so
they misconstrue the point I'm making my
advice to guys is you are likely not
going to find a healthy relationship in
a big city just going to like normal
Hangouts where people your age go
because Millennial women are like 78
Democrat overwhelmingly so you're going
to find whatever this person's views are
tremendous social pressure in their
circles to reject whatever it is you
might want to bring to the table so uh
the simple way to put it is you might
meet a woman who she's very much like
want to have a family and have kids and
then you're like this is someone I can
date and then every person they know and
every social media account and everyone
who follows them and they follow is
screaming be a CEO and don't have kids
and so they're being pushed in both
directions yeah and look I I will say
because I didn't mean to like rip on
those guys that much I just think it's
like silly to like be debating with
these like young chicks or whatever but
look I like I do think there is some
there's a reason they exist they're like
a necessary pushback well it's because
the insanity the dating feminism yeah
and and it's really funny when you think
about it how much this mentality has
destroyed relationships and families in
this country along with a lot of other
policies that have made it unaffordable
to buy a home or to you know like send
kids to college and things like this but
there is something to like where you go
look this whole idea that they're like
well you know back in the 50s women were
subservient to their husbands and you're
like so now they're subservient to their
bosses it doesn't get better is that
better better to be like subservient to
someone who's not even like raising your
kids with you did you see the clip from
the whatever podcast where the woman
says if if a guy she wants to date
doesn't have a girlfriend or isn't
sleeping with other women she assumes
something is wrong with him yeah but but
again it's like the the thing that I
think might be misleading about some of
these shows is that they go and they go
see that's women you know what I mean
well now you're like no no it's like
that's clearly the woman you don't want
to be in a relationship with agreed but
there's like there are a ton of like
really great like women out there who
are don't have crazy attitudes like that
who will make like really good wives and
mothers it's not impossible to find them
all this is the flaw in a lot of that
like manosphere logic too where like
they they take some things that are
somewhat true and then extrapolate that
they're like laws where they're like
look what women want is a guy who's like
tall and is making money and is doing
this who's dominant who's all of this
like okay yes there's some truth that a
lot of those characteristics are
attractive to women the truth is that
like okay like you could be uh like a
tall Rich Charming guy and all through
throughout this country there are
plumbers whose wives you couldn't pull
from them yeah they would never in a
million years fool around behind their
husband's back no matter what you were
because they're in love with their
husband and he get he makes them happy
and like they're all right though man
yeah well I'm just saying I just meant I
don't know no not insulting plus I I
enjoy their services I got a better one
for you yeah there are unemployed Street
musicians who are living at home with
the women with with their wives who are
doing heavy lifting who will not cheat
or leave their husbands because they
love him and the relationship super
devoted and this is this is I'm what I'm
saying is think about a guy who's like
I'm gonna make it as a musician honey I
just need more time and she's like
sooner or later you got to get a job but
she still won't leave him or cheat on
him even though he's not successful yeah
it's like a lot of these stories are
like women want a man who's dominating
and tells them what to do and it's like
then then what about all the dudes who
are like losers who have these wives who
won't leave them despite the fact
they're not succeeding like love is
dynamic you know and the reason I use
the example I use was more like look I
think that relationship probably is more
vulnerable there still are lots of
chicks who like won't like are in love
with that guy but I just mean like
there's guys who just do the job of like
being like hey I work every day I take
care of you I'm a good husband and they
have like loyal wives who like are great
to them and like that's I'll just say
it's it's a really a it's a great thing
to have from my perspective having a
really great wife it makes life like so
many so much so much better than you
could have imagined it would be that I
just don't like the idea of anyone
talking to young men and like
discouraging them to like that being a
possibility for potentially finding like
it's like you can't you can't now it is
true like take some of that Jordan
Peterson advice get yourself together
improve yourself make yourself more of
the person who will like will attract
women to you but then when you do that
find a great one but Peterson's
different than like the red oh yeah no
he's the best of that kind of guy yes it
is self-help and it applies and also
because he's not a kid because he's a
guy in a happy marriage you know what I
mean well I think part of it is like
Duality I think right now like we're
talking about with abortion like if you
take away some things that we have right
now modern culture there is no reason to
pursue high quality people because the
family unit doesn't matter and so
therefore like what is the point of
finding someone high quality they're
going to be with long-term monogamously
through thick and thin kind of thing
right like I find myself thinking all
the time like I wish we would return
return voting rights just to like
married men who own property because if
you had to be married and own property
and like to vote I feel like our system
would be totally different it's a start
yeah
so that part and then we strip those
guys yes
have you seen the family Dave's here you
see the Family Guy joke about this where
it's like it was a flashback and then
it's Peter Griffin talking to someone
and he's like you know okay you're free
but you can't vote because it was like
Civil War or something and then he was
like only white people can vote except
for then he starts naming all of the
other groups that technically like and
there's like you know what no voting for
anybody nobody can vote like that's
somewhere else well look I mean I will
say that I think
um look see if you're the only person in
this room or maybe I don't know about
this but like you would be our voting
Block in this room right and if I was
the only person in the country I tell
you I'd be really on board with this uh
plan but well look if you look at say
like zumat say like the last hundred
years broadly speaking like go to like
Woodrow Wilson's Administration to Joe
Biden's Administration and you just look
at how much bigger the government has
gotten like in all of these increments
right you have like the creation of the
Federal Reserve and the income tax do
you have fdrs uh the New Deal you have
the expansions during World War One
during World War II you have
um you have the Great Society under
Lyndon Johnson you have you know
whatever everything from there George W
bush and Barack Obama and all the way
through to the present and you look at
how much the culture has like like been
degraded and it's not a coincidence that
like as the state expands your culture
gets more destroyed and if you look at
it through every inch of it right like
through even the creation of say like
Social Security it's like okay well
without Social Security what used to be
the retirement plan well the retirement
plan used to be your kids would take
care of you so you're just like
incentivizing people to take really good
care of their kids so that their kids
then want to take care of them before
the rise of the welfare state what was
the welfare state it was your local
community it was your local church it's
like there's all of these incentives to
kind of like we build communities for a
reason because there's natural
incentives for us to all work together
and kind of like be interdependent and
then the state comes in at every turn it
like undermines like all of those
cultural norms and and like incentivizes
you to be dependent on the state and
it's horrible how uh where are the
politicians campaigning on just say like
ending the income tax yeah I mean it was
unbelievable to me that during I mean I
was screaming at the top of my lungs for
as many people who could hear this but
even during the whole like uh during the
all the covet Insanity they're like hey
you want to figure out how to get it's
so funny watch the federal government
say we're trying to figure out how to
get Aid to the American people who we
rob half their income from like how
about
three years of the we're pausing the
index you know like a tax holidays but
something like that and and why no one
would be you know talking about this
thing that is the biggest bill for so
many families around the country it's
but but think about this they did the
stimulus the uh they did the extended
unemployment plus the stimulus because
of covid and the the complaint from a
lot of people was that Democrats are
basically bribing voters saying vote for
me and I'm gonna give you money
okay so one Republicans would be alike
we'll get rid of the income tax
Libertarians I mean obviously but you
know conservatives should be campaigning
on that they get every vote if if you
can if Donald Trump came out and said
please you don't like me I know but I'm
gonna abolish taxes on you so you'll
have a lot of free money then Democrats
might be like oh I hate Trump I'm gonna
vote for that guy well tax cuts do tend
to be popular I think that you know with
the issue that people have with it is
that
if in order to do something like that
you people would recognize that there'd
have to be drastic Cuts in spending
along with it because our government
just spends so much damn money and so
nobody wants to touch that including
every rep every Republican president uh
of my lifetime including Donald Trump
trump should do it yeah I look I agree
with you Donald Trump
needs to do a campaign video where he's
like wearing the cloak and he and then
there's like fires behind him and he's
like I am shutting down the Federal
Reserve the income tax Vengeance will be
mine I'd be like I'm voting for that but
it's just the most insane I mean I love
this is a Scott Horton's analogy not
mine
um but so shout out to the Great Scott
Horton
um but uh he always says this which is
just what you really think about just
how insane the income tax in the IRS are
especially in a professed capitalist
country but he would go imagine the
Soviet Union invaded and conquered the
United States of America so we're a free
country and the Soviet Union invades and
conquers us we never had anything like
the IRS before and then they come in and
they say we are creating the USS IRS uh
it is now a crime to produce something
it's a crime to make money in this
country and the punishment for the crime
is a fee and the more you produce the
higher your fee goes and we've repealed
the Fifth Amendment you no longer have a
right to not incriminate yourself you
must incriminate yourself every single
year to the government who will then
assess what this what how much you've
produced and therefore what your
punishment should be how high your fee
is and if you lie when you're
incriminating yourself we will throw you
in jail and if we feel that you if we
decide that you've miscalculated we'll
go back 20 years and just absolutely
destroy you like if that was the case it
would be so obvious to all of us what
happened we went oh we were conquered
and now we live under totalitarianism
yet we our own government does it to us
and people are just kind of like well
you know this is a government Department
you want to know why I'm absolutely sure
and it's soon enough everyone's gonna
have the neural link port on their necks
and they'll be plugged into the Matrix
or the metaverse because we all have
government mandated identification
numbers multiple of them you get your
driver's license or ID you've got an ID
number on that card but when you're born
they give you your official government
tracking number congratulations now that
that like think about that analogy about
Soviet Union and go back a hundred years
and people are going to be like the
government's going to do what yeah track
me by number what now it's like everyone
has one it's totally normal
so it's going to be normal this
expansion it just keeps happening the
the likelihood in my opinion is is 100
well the thing about it is is that like
like uh parasites tend to eventually
kill the host and I was thinking of
maybe a more optimistic metaphor than
that uh but there there it does seem
like something we're living through
something very big right now and Empires
do collapse and we do seem to have all
of the signs of a collapsing Empire but
I got a better analogy not parasite
symbiote like Venom okay actually I
think it is a much better uh analogy
because if you think about it for those
that are uh you know for those that are
fans of Spider-Man you'll probably
understand this do you know anything
about like the Venom character no I
don't the the Symbiote attaches to Eddie
Brock and then tells him it's going to
give him everything he wants make him
powerful get his revenge makes him more
aggressive and angry that's literally
what happened the United States had this
this group come in the Jekyll Island say
we're going to do this thing it's going
to stabilize your economy it's me so
good for you it's gonna make everything
better and then turn to the country into
a weapon made it angry and aggressive
and imperialist yeah I mean yeah okay I
like that analogy a lot actually I will
say though I think the um I think the
biggest story in the world right now is
um what just happened over the last
couple weeks with uh uh she going to uh
Russia and working out this deal with
Vladimir Putin they've got Brazil on
board they've got India on board they
the Chinese have now brokered a somewhat
of a normalizing uh normalization of
relations between Saudi Arabia and Iran
it's like you're seeing like in 1991
after the Soviet Union uh collapsed the
late
um evil Charles crowdenhamer dubbed it
the unipolar moment
um it seems like we're witnessing the
end of the unipolar moment like we're no
longer in just an america-dominated
world and it's it's quite something
that's just like the hubris of all of
these warhawks in DC that one year into
this war in Ukraine and you're like oh
that's not how the plan was supposed to
go now is it but democracy ain't
sweeping the region after we overthrew
Saddam is it but I think Donald Trump
saw this the one of the reasons he
wanted to run securing our borders
bringing manufacturing back was because
the U.S unipolar world was destabilizing
and the only way that people like
Hillary Clinton the Deep state were able
to maintain it was by further spreading
thin expending resources and it was
crumbling and so Trump is like we're
going to make this country great we're
gonna bring back jobs we're going to
secure our borders we've got to get a
control on this because otherwise if we
allow the Deep State Biden Democrat
whoever is is running the show to keep
doing this we're going to spread so thin
it's just going to snap and then the
United States will be left holding an
empty bag if Donald Trump was the
president we'd have more manufacturing
we'd have a secure border and then when
the unipolar shift happens to a
multipolar shift we're still much more
self-sufficient and better off oh yeah I
mean look I gotta say I I think the
world and America would be better off
without America being the dominant like
hegemon like I don't think that's done
any favors for the American people I
think that like it's just allowed us to
expand our resources and spread them
thinner and thinner don't get me wrong
it's been really great for Raytheon and
it's been really great for JP Morgan
Chase and like is it some people have
benefited the average American I don't
believe has
um I think that Donald Trump did see
America in Decline and felt like it was
for a lot of very stupid reasons like
this is what he would say he's like well
we're fighting stupid Wars and we're
making stupid trade deals and we're you
know and we're like we have flooding
with immigration this doesn't make sense
but he appreciated how much this was
directly related to the increase in
government spending and the zero
interest rates for over a decade that he
inherited the the reason why the Deep
state was engaging in war and stupid
trade deals is to prop up the Petro
Dollar by forcing countries who would
try to oppose us to to uh Gaddafi Saddam
Hussein they wanted to get off the
dollar they get wiped out the reason why
we were doing these awful trade deals
the the simplest example would
understand this is the Pakistani gender
studies Grant it was like 12 million
dollars for gender studies programs in
Pakistan now everyone laughs and says
it's the stupidest thing I ever heard
but the idea is if the U.S can print the
money and give it out it maintains
confidence in that currency it may
weaken it through inflation but it makes
sure those people use it so you'll get
this country you'll get Pakistan get to
this point of course that money's not
going to gender studies they're going to
steal and they're going to use it
whatever they want but if you've got a
guy who's just given a million dollars
he wants that million dollars to be
worth something so he goes to another
guy and the guy says I don't want U.S
dollars he goes I only trade in US
dollars so I'm rich and I got US Dollars
okay fine we'll use US Dollars the U.S
does this stuff with bad trade deals
giving money away on purpose and then
blowing up anybody who won't use the
dollar yeah it's over that's over well
it's it seems like it's the beginning of
that of the end for the Petro dollar now
what exactly that's going to mean I
don't know but it's big they're talking
about the cbdc starting the the Central
Bank uh yeah digital currency in July
now yeah there's been a lot of talk of
this they're trying to gauge it and this
is why I say like it's the most
important issue to like spread awareness
about right now so that people go like
listen under no circumstances do you go
for this because what's going on right
now and this is something that happens a
lot is they put these feelers out and
they gauge how much resistance there is
to this but like the white pill in all
of this is that if there's too much
resistance they will pull back this idea
if you remember Joe Biden floated out
um National vaccine passports and they
float this out through like their
corporate press outlets and they go oh
we're talking about this and then there
was a big uproar about it and then they
pulled it back they go no no we were
never talking about never talking about
Obama announced that we were going to
invade Syria there was a huge pushback
to it and he pulled it back we didn't
invade Syria we only covertly funded
Isis but that story for another day uh
but even with uh like sopa if you guys
remember the plant the original plan of
regulating yes that's right uh they they
floated this out there was too much
resistance and they pulled it back so
like there is actually a lot of power
there's a reason why they try to
propagandize people there's a reason why
they use propaganda because they
recognize that they actually do have to
like have at least a level of tacid
support to get these policies through so
like the Central Bank digital currency
is the big one right now to me like
oppose that as vocally and as loudly as
you can how they feel like they have to
pull this back because that's game over
for US unless there's a major crisis
so that makes it tougher have you seen
that Balaji guy predict a couple of
weeks ago that Bitcoin would be I think
it was like a month ago now Bitcoin
would hit a million dollars in 90 days
yeah yeah you heard people talking about
that he was talking about how I think
it's like treasury bonds are a a
negative asset so the the interest rates
on them is lower than the interest rates
by the fed and the inflation so they're
guaranteed once they mature to be a loss
for the banking institutions these
unrealized losses will cause a Cascade
which basically destroys these Banks we
started seeing glimpses of it with svb
with what was it silvergate first
Republic and then uh uh Sovereign I
think it was and so
if they are planning and they've
mentioned launching the cbdc by July the
only way they can effectively do it is
if there is a major crisis now imagine
this because our our audience has
already heard me mention this but I'm
curious your thoughts
a major Bank collapses like I'm talking
like a huge Branch maybe not a regional
something bigger
and then you get a major newsbreak of
Wells Fargo or something right something
are they still around I know they had a
big brother yeah so let's say there's a
big collapse at like Wells Fargo we're
talking about millions of people saying
I can't get my money out Joe Biden comes
out and says my fellow Americans those
who have been impacted by the collapse
of these Banks fear not your money is
insured and covered simply download fed
coin dot app and log in using your
social security number and all of your
currency will have been preserved and
converted to the new Central Bank
digital currency saving your assets and
then people will say thank you Joe Biden
as they log into adopt cbdc yeah well I
mean hopefully we can kind of wake as
many people up as possible to what
that'll really mean yeah but yeah what
what what is what does a dad do when one
day he's told if you want to buy
groceries you must use cbdc yeah that's
that's a tough choice I mean like yeah
wait so you'll probably be able to get
yes the Central Bank digital currency
um look what's going on here that is but
what I find to be more likely if there's
a lot of pushback to this idea of a
central bank digital currency is that
they're just going to lower interest
rates again and kick the can down the
road for another few years I think
that's where we're going is back down to
zero percent interest rates when all of
these Banks really start failing which I
think is inevitable and this is kind of
like if you know if you're familiar with
like the uh Austrian uh economics which
is the only good economics out there I
really encourage everybody if you're
interested in the topic to look them up
um basically the way like the boom bust
Cycle Works is that when you have
artificially low interest rates you
build up bubbles when the rates start
inevitably coming up those bubbles burst
it's basically like this false it's like
price fixing like anything else when you
fix the price of the cost of money which
is all interest rates are is the price
of money when you fix those you get
Investments you wouldn't otherwise have
people borrow money when there's very
low interest when they wouldn't have
borrowed that money at a high interest
rate loan because that that makes it
profitable however once the interest
rates start to come up as is inevitable
then they realize oh this project was
was never should have been uh you know
like started to begin with and then you
have this whole collapse all of these
banks are completely built now because
this insane policy which is if we
survive historians will write books
about how crazy it was that anyone let
this happen that we had from literally
from 2008 through with slight
interruptions almost through 2021 we had
zero percent interest rates there was
Zero the FED fund rate was either zero
or or a quarter of a point or something
insanely low and all of these banks have
been built off of that at this point and
so like what you're talking about with
the interest rates rising and then the
the treasury is becoming completely
worthless or even a loss in some cases
that's one aspect of it there's several
but the a lot of these things there's
still people in adjustable rate
mortgages out there they can't afford
these interest rates going up anymore
and just for a little bit of perspective
effective you know in for what volcker
had to do under Ronald Reagan to reign
in the inflation of the 70s he brought
the FED fund rate up to 20 percent yep
okay now can you now the thing is they
weren't 30 trillion dollars in debt back
then we can't do anything like that or
it would pop this entire bubble so we're
in a bad spot
yeah I say just we got to get it over
with man that we'd be better off in the
long term this is another Insight of
like the Austrian uh Economist that like
you're basically you're better off in
the long term to feel the pain now and
then at least start building from yes
yes but the reason why they're drawing
it out
the Titanic has hit the iceberg they
don't want the people on the ship to
know because they'll Panic so they are
loading up as much Fine China into these
stations that's a very good analogy and
they're going down the safety boat
everything's fine everybody everybody's
don't worry we're just gonna be over
here and you're like why are they in the
Lifeboat and leaving everybody should
everybody that listens to like stuff
that's whether it be Libertarians or
stuff like you know center right you
know this kind of stuff everyone know
has known that this has been coming like
that the US has been giving money away
for a decade that the government is
completely irresponsible with the
monetary policy and I don't want to
sound like a like a you know insensitive
or whatever but it's like people have
been saying buy guns for a decade people
have been saying like buy ammo buy food
learn to do things I mean Tim's been
talking about chickens for five years
now like not for nothing and I
understand that there are always people
that are learning about this stuff and
finding out but like the the people that
have been putting the this off like you
have literally it's possible that you
only have months before there's a
serious credit crisis I I I wanna I
wanna say this again because I said this
the other day I said it my morning show
we make fun of these soy boys these
antifa scrawny gaunt soy boys who get
arrested firebombing buildings
and there are many people who listen to
shows like this who are like well I
can't speak up I'll I'll lose my job and
it's just like
how are they the soy boys yeah these far
leftists are willing to like destroy
everything in the psychotic rage call
them something else you know yeah and
like I can understand people being
afraid of risk and all that I'm just
saying like
take stock of like where you are at and
your ability to stand up to the problems
this country is facing and what
precautions and actions you've taken to
protect yourself and your family before
you start casting stones at soy boys
right and you can take minor steps to
live your values right you don't have to
confront everyone all the time if you
like put your jobs at risk but like
don't continue to consent to everything
that happens right right micro changes
that are manageable so you are not just
giving in yeah at least try to start
putting yourself in a position where
your job wouldn't be at risk you know
what I mean like try to at least start
like protecting yourself where like you
would be able to speak up about you what
you want look I mean the fair obviously
there's an asymmetry between who they're
calling the soy boys on the left and
these guys like the system is designed
to protect those guys and the system
will come crash down on you we are
really living in anarch or tyranny as
Sam Francis would have called it um you
see Donald Trump will get arrested
because there's so many damn laws on the
books that they have a new law they can
use against him while rapists and
murderers will go hold on where is any
conservative prosecutor in this country
to go after Obama and the Democrats for
campaign Finance violations one time one
one count one charge one misdemeanor
anything I'll take whatever I can get
yeah there's plenty there yeah there's
plenty of stuff there right and and Greg
vomits all over himself an embarrassing
in an embarrassing fashion but he didn't
care that it's like that story I tell
where the Taco Bell employed the black
lives matter mask on and they said take
it off for your fire he goes then I got
some fired made a video saying how dare
you and they rehired him saying we're
sorry Greg will indict Trump on BS and
conservatives will be like slope out
there Democrats well you know this was
the the kind of like the most like
annoying Boomer con like National Review
talking point about Donald Trump being
impeached is they're like well this is
just gonna lead to like now everyone's
gonna impeach every president and then
the next president will be impeached
like now there's no political will on
the Republican side to impeach Joe Biden
right now right and the because the
reason really is is that they're all in
the same club like they're they're the
Globetrotters and the generals they're
playing their positions the Republicans
up there in Capitol Hill they're on the
same team they're just they're there to
be the generals they're there to say
like we stood up against this and then
we got walked over or whatever so that
no that's not actually what's happening
you know you know this reminds me of
it's a Simpsons bit where you know Crush
has got a gambling problem I think it's
Barney's like you bet against the
Globetrotters and he's like I thought
the generals were due like dude we keep
betting on these Republicans but they're
just there to pretend to oppose
democrats for the most part it's a small
handful that do Thomas Massey is pretty
good yeah Matt Gates is pretty good and
it's not that they're afraid to use
state power you know by the way oh my
God it bothered me to no end when a few
months ago when uh um uh what's his name
I'm sorry I'm blanking on his name
Michael Knowles was on the show and he
got into a little bit of an argument
with uh um with Luke uh but when he was
saying which I think is there's this new
kind of like right wing like narrative
that which I is really kind of
entertaining to me where they go you
know the problem is that Libertarians
convinced the Republicans that you can't
use the state and so we decided that
okay we agreed yeah using the government
is I think he said it's a priori wrong
and so then what happened was the left
just took over all of these institutions
and that's kind of a nice story I I
understand where it would make some
right-wingers feel good uh about the
story but objectively it's not what
happened it's not at all what happened
what actually happened was that the
Republicans who had the support of all
the conservatives in the country decided
to completely abandon any libertarian
principle that they had and they you
know while Libertarians were screaming
at them from the top of our lungs that
like you're creating the Department of
Homeland Security this will be a
nightmare this will be used against
American citizens they were like no no
we're fighting terrorism and when we
told them don't fight this war and Iraq
they were like no no no we're spreading
freedom and don't pass the Patriot Act
and all of these things they they
ignored us they they went all in on
state power and now that state power is
being used against those people it's a
like horrifically tragic ironic thing
that the voters who supported George W
bush creating the Department of Homeland
Security are now the targets of the
Department of Homeland Security and then
you get Luke talking about how he goes
out to rallies and he's got these people
used to be staunch conservatives or
neocon being like you were right about
everything yeah well that's the weird
thing is that they'll admit we're right
about everything in the past but then
they also won't like but then as soon as
we tell them like what we think they
should do now they go all right lolbert
like whatever you know
even when you see the other day when
it's like these people like advocating
for uh gun control against transgender
people or whatever after this shooting
and then like some libertarian will be
like you know they'll make the point
that you're like um you know if you
Advocate that the government can take
away your guns because you have a mental
illness they're gonna decide that racism
is a mental illness pretty soon and
anything you say is racism take away
your guns and then they'll be like
they're already against us so it and
you're like dude it can get worse don't
think it can't get it but could you
imagine let me just say that you imagine
if the Le if the guy who told you don't
create the Department of Homeland
Security or you could be the target of
it and then you did it and then you're
the target of it and they go hey don't
create this next thing or you could be
the target of it and they go whatever
idiots yeah but they're all right but
but not this time yeah not this time
Michael malis talks about this he said
that people really don't understand how
bad bad could be yes that they're that
you've got people on the right saying
like oh it's so bad right now he's like
you don't know how bad he's absolutely
right someone should make him press
secretary there was just absolutely
right so the story uh uh I like to tell
is my Ukrainian friend saying that uh I
was I was when I was in Ukraine covering
a lot of these these the the you're my
dance stuff started what became the
separatist start of what became the War
I guess although it can go back far uh
she was telling me that the apartment
she was in like 30 some odd years ago
there were neighbors they lived next to
each other they were fighting because
they're Neighbors so the person in her
unit called the police and said I
overheard my neighbor saying
anti-government things and the next day
the apartment was cleaned out and the
person was gone so when what year was
this in I don't know 70s or something
maybe oh okay long time ago maybe maybe
earlier it was a story might have been
the 50s she was just saying like the
these houses were all the Communist
blackouts right okay yeah and she was
like the story they passed down and she
was like I live here there was a person
who lived here in the Soviet Union who
got mad at a neighbor and that's what
they could just do when they got married
all they do is they called the cops said
they were saying things against the
party and the next day they were gone
everything that got like apartment was
empty yeah and like right so it's like
and this is kind of like I think part of
the message of of Michael malice's uh
last book the white pill or maybe just
kind of like what I took from it but the
the message is kind of like look it can
get so bad you know what I mean like it
can be so much worse than you can even
conceive of but then it also kind of
makes you think like look there are also
like little signs of things kind of like
this that we're doing now so hey let's
really make sure we don't go down that
path because you know even when they
were encouraging people during covid
remember there were ports where it's
like oh there was this this hotlines
where you could text and mention if
someone was having a gathering or
something still government agencies that
tweet out if you see something say
something they've been doing it for the
past 20 years since the G Watch started
and it's well it started it after like 9
11. yeah it was like hey if you see a
Muslim planting a bomb on a building or
something and then it turned into like
now three people hanging out yeah right
like maybe I I ask people to think of it
this way uh you ever see a rabbit you
saw in the middle nowhere you imagine
why that rabbit must feel right just a
tightly wound ball of anxiety scared the
entire time and sometimes when they're
safe you know they Frolic around they
they bounce and they do fun bunny things
you see them flop on their side for
those that have rabbits but when I go
outside I see the bunnies
a better example actually is the
groundhog outside there's a window right
here today when I was recording earlier
I got up to close the window and I saw a
groundhog and when I closed the window
the simple very very quiet noise made
the thing spaz out and run in random
directions
imagine what that thing must be feeling
right that's how you will feel if this
country goes down that path you'll be
sitting in your home
stressed out with bags under your eyes
rocking back and forth eating a bowl of
soup and then you'll hear a knock on the
door
and then you'll go and you'll answer it
and you will pray that it's not the
Gestapo the Stasi the police or the the
the brown shirts or whoever and then one
day it will be and that's it and it just
and it doesn't have to be this way you
know like that's kind of like my biggest
like message that it's like it doesn't
have to be this way it didn't have to go
this way in the past there's nothing
like predestined about that I think this
is one of the things that like the
neo-reactionary types get completely
wrong where they're like oh it was all
written in the stars since the
enlightenment that this would follow
this and this would follow this it's
like no that's not true it wasn't
written in the stars that the Soviet
Union would collapse in 1991 it wasn't
written in the stars that like a lot of
things that have happened have happened
and there we could have look even
something as similar as like as simple
as like look if George W bush just
hadn't won the presidency which was a
very very close election there wouldn't
have been a war in Iraq now I'm not
saying everything would have been better
I think Al Gore would not have begun to
warn Iraq that was something that that
specific group of neoconservatives had a
boner for since they wrote it since they
wrote it in the project for a New
American Century that was not something
that like was widely now once it started
a lot of them fell in line with that but
I'm just saying that like there's no
reason why we had to go down this path
that we've gone down the last 20 years
I'm not saying everything would have
been perfect but we could have done
things a lot better and we could stop
now and make the future much better this
country still has an unbelievable
opportunity if you just think about the
fact that like think about the amount of
just knowledge we have how much human
capital there is just in our knowledge
today what the average say like uh
cardiologist knows that a cardiologist
didn't know in 1950. now short of a
hydrogen bomb going off that knowledge
is not going to be is disappeared but
our Engineers know the amount of
technology that we have we have all of
these things where we could actually
correct course right now and just live
in a more peaceful harmonious world but
it's only going to happen if there's
like a mass demand for it you know it's
crazy just as an aside if you went back
in time two thousand years
with your general knowledge of things
that exist today
without knowing how how an h-bomb is
menu is made without knowing how to make
an electric motor if you simply wrote
down these things and said electricity
electric motor it would dramatically
increase scientific development for
those people by hundreds of years just
simply knowing a thing exists
because one of the challenges is that
for all of us in society we are mapping
things out and discovering things and
then after we discover it we start
experimenting with it if we skip the
discovery phase and say it exists figure
it out people would rapidly just rapidly
discover these things if they believed
you because if you went back three
thousand years ago if they didn't they'd
be like it just sounds like magic
there's some comedian who talks about
like I don't think I could make it he'd
be like you know phones you'll be able
to carry one around your pocket and
they're they're going to ask him like
how does that happen I'm pretty sure
Nate bargatzi is who you're probably I
wish I knew his name it's such a funny
an amazing comedian a great person he
does this yeah he's got this bit he goes
that he couldn't even convince them I
think it's got something to do with
satellites like I go back in time and do
worse because I couldn't it's such a fun
it's such a funny bit like he'd have
like no follow-up you go like I think
it's satellites and they're like what's
a satellite he's like
I shouldn't have even brought it up
that's such a great bit hilarious
comedian neighbors but think about think
about that because I've talked about it
too uh in terms of if we do face a a
serious collapse what is more worrying
to me than a nuclear bomb going off an
EMP drone weapon or even the sun
bursting and weapon Electronics is
economic crisis yes I agree with you if
if the economy stops then you're not
going to have computers you're not going
to have cars you're not going to have
electronics and it's not because a
magical explosion from the Sun wiped it
out it's going to be because people
aren't working together because the
economic machine itself is a powerful
system that if you break one peg and it
can collapse yeah and and this is when
really bad things happen when there's a
really bad economy right like oh if you
want if you look back at any like
horrible totalitarian movement it almost
always started with like there was a
real economic crash
issue going on in the U.S and we are in
a proxy war with the country that has
the most nuclear weapons on the planet
and people just go to go about their
normal days like that is just the way
things are or that it's okay look there
should be the it should be the most
important thing is is just stopping well
you don't want to have it's like a slow
boil right like people got eased into
the economic turmoil and then they got
used to it and then they got used to
everyone talking about Ukraine we had
the moment wherever and put up their
flags and then it sort of it's been
happening in the background for like a
year how we got here is yeah I get it
you're maybe right how we got here is
not important just because of the
ramifications of something going wrong
well the thing is that is this right and
when you talk about like kind of like
the economic uh the the the prospects of
a really terrible economic situation
there's this uh by the way the great
book if anyone wants to read it called
uh the Forgotten crash of 1921 by James
Grant really excellent book so in 1921 a
lot of people don't know this there was
a crash that was worse than the stock
market crash of 1929 which led to the
Great Depression
um but at the time
um the basic the Federal Reserve was
created in in 2013 there wasn't much I'm
sorry 1913. there wasn't much of a um
there wasn't much of uh um like a
federal regulatory apparatus yet it
hadn't really come in
um the government was just kind of like
weak compared to form and so basically
they did nothing there was no
intervention and the Crash was over
within a year it was a bad year and then
the economy totally recovered and all of
so there is this natural cleansing
mechanism like it basically what I'm
trying to say is with all of our modern
technology today if we were to just get
the government out of the way if we were
to just let the market work if we were
to just we could cleanse out all of
these problems and we could be fine we
could very easily negotiate a piece in
Ukraine it is so simple it's so obvious
what needs to happen it's like look
um and and this is a bitter pill for
some to swallow but it's the reality
Crimea is Russia's it's not going back
here's the truth it never really wasn't
theirs it was always theirs it's
basically been there since the 1780s
they allowed Ukraine to have
Independence if they leased out this
Naval Base the second that the Ukrainian
Government after it was overthrown by a
coup that was backed by the West in 2014
they said you got to get that yeah well
they and we talk more about that I would
love to but they said you they tore up
the lease and Vladimir Putin said no now
they they claimed Vladimir Putin invaded
Ukraine I mean excuse me invaded Crimea
it's true that he sent in some
reinforcements
he didn't really invade they left the
base they walked outside and they went
this is ours now right it was a
bloodless coup domain they was there
already there was yes there was I mean
maybe like four people died or something
like that and it was not even like from
the Russians it was like in some
protests and stuff it's not exactly
clear but this wasn't like some bloody
invasion they just walked out most of
the people there wanted to be with
Russia it's majority ethnic Russian and
they had their huge base there that's
not going anywhere the Don bass region
they're probably going to have to be
given independence of some sort west of
there should be returned to Ukraine and
it should be demanded that if we
guarantee Ukraine will never be a part
of NATO then Vladimir Putin pulls all of
his presence back from west of the
donbass region that offer would end the
war tomorrow the pro this is literally
what the deal was that they had worked
out when Boris Johnson went over last
year to tell them not the ukrainians not
to agree to this as was reported by
Fiona Hill not a Libertarian Dove Fiona
Hill even reported this right so we
could work that out and the Bloodshed
could end tomorrow except you got idiots
like Joe Biden and then people in the
Press like Pierce Morgan going not one
inch he shouldn't get one inch why
should he get anything it's like oh so
that we don't keep yeah tens of
thousands of people dying literally for
the next five years and so that there's
not ultimately a nuclear war that's why
and because like whether luhansk is
ruled by Kiev or Moscow is not more
important than whether we go to nuclear
war I'm sorry Dave whether luhansk is
ruled by Kiev or Moscow is of no matter
to me at all at all you'd struggle to
find something lower my list of
priorities to be fair I I have I having
been to the country meeting people there
I have friends but they don't live in
that region and many of them left the
country sadly and so it's like I don't
know like point one percent like I don't
want them to suffer I feel bad for them
but I don't think about Ukraine in that
way I I'm really worried about the
southern border and our economy yeah and
look by the way just to the point I was
making before it's like oh the the
correct answers to all of these problems
are actually fairly obvious the
challenge is actually getting the
Psychopaths who rule us to implement any
of them and I'm not pretending to have
an easy answer to any of that but also
just with this Ukraine thing man it's
like it's been funny because I like uh
you know I've gotten when I was on Rogan
last time I they they clipped you know
the segment where I was talking about
this it went like super viral so it's
been so funny to get like all the
pushback from like all the blue checks I
mean now everyone has a blue check but
before women and they're getting rid of
theirs yeah I know but but at the time
it was before Elon took it over
um and getting all the pushback from all
of them and it's just so hilarious to
see where the they're all like try to
argue like nah it wasn't America
provoking this this war has nothing to
do with NATO expansion this war has
nothing to do with us overthrowing the
government of Ukraine this war has
nothing to do with us flooding in
weapons after we uh installed the
pro-western uh government to Ukraine and
you're like dude I mean you're just so
removed from the reality of what's going
on here and it's not just like things
it's not just like oh the wacky
Libertarians or the crazy anti-war
leftists are saying this even the people
within the National Security apparatus
knew this the current CIA director wrote
a cable do you ever read this Tim the
net means yet uh so okay this is a
secret this was not like a public like
released document he the current uh
Burns who's the head of the CIA he was
the ambassador to Russia in 2008 and he
wrote a memo back to Condoleezza Rice we
only have this memo because Julian
Assange dumped it okay it's the only
reason we know about this like he wrote
Amendment this is not what he's telling
the public this is what he's telling his
boss the Secretary of State just so she
knows and he goes look I'm here in
Russia and over the last few years I got
to tell you the idea of Ukraine entering
NATO is the brightest of red lines and
this is not just the brightest of red
lines to Putin he goes the entire
Russian Elite like from the craziest
right Wingers to Putin's sharpest
liberal critics he goes I've yet to meet
one person who sees Ukrainian intro and
entry into NATO as anything other than a
direct challenge to Russia and he goes
on to say that this will be lead to
fertile ground he's putting it in
diplomatic language
lead to fertile ground for intervention
in Crimea and Ukraine he tells them now
three months after that at the Bucharest
Summit NATO announced Ukraine and Crimea
will be uh joining NATO can I three
months after that he uh goes to war with
uh um with Georgia I I just like to read
something
is the Chief Executive Officer of
barisma Holdings we'll skip forward a
little bit it says in 2017 Joseph Coffer
black former director of the
counterterrorism center of the CIA in
the George W Bush Administration and
former Ambassador at large for counter
Terror was appointed to the board
yeah so uh and this is around the same
time that he appointed Hunter Biden
2017. yeah 27. and you know Hunter Biden
was 2015 maybe uh 2014 I believe okay
2014 so so and Hunter Biden were
appointed the board I bring this up just
for one reason you mentioned all these
people who are like we didn't provoke we
didn't do this I have not had a single
conversation with a liberal and
supportive Ukraine war who could tell me
what barisma is what gas prom is and
what the cutter turkey pipeline are yeah
no they have no idea but listen and the
thing the deal with Barista the reason
why they're putting all these people on
their boards is essentially they were
essentially like cronies of the
yanakovich government and by the way
janakovich was a real corrupt government
Ukraine's always been a crazy corrupt
country there's like I don't have the
exact numbers of this of him but
janakovich's son was I think like the
fifth richest person in Ukraine and he
was a dentist
like there wasn't even like a plausible
reason but now again we can be
judgmental but Nancy Pelosi is also
worth like a few hundred million dollars
and we gotta you know we got a fair
amount of this stuff going on here too
but janakovich was democratically
elected and he the elections were
verified by the EU and like so there's
no one's really like claiming that and
the the maidon revolution this bloody
street punch was completely backed by
the West you can look at a million
different angles where it was funded by
George soros's website brags about how
they were instrumental in organizing the
the protest movement uh of course um
Victoria Newland was going over there
multiple trips just passing out food and
water you had McCain and Murphy and
Lindsey Graham all these Senators
meeting them billions of dollars of U.S
Aid flowing into the country all types
of of this like involvement but barisma
was in with the yanakovich government
so when the U.S backed coup overthrew
the yanukovic government they were
freaked out and they were like oh no
where do we stand now so instead of just
bribing the pashinko government they
went right to the source and they go
we'll just put the vice president's kid
on our board we'll hire former CIA guys
we'll get there so they basically in in
essence they protected themselves with
the new regime by just bribing who they
knew the real boss of the new regime was
which was the USA
I just find all of this to be like if
you track the history of the region the
energy crisis the energy competition
it's fairly obvious what's going on and
like you pointed out with Crimea this is
Russia's I believe their only warm water
Port yes yes the only uh year-long War
more report and it's their access to the
Mediterranean and the U.S was basically
like not anymore so of course Russia's
only move was going to be it's Russia
now yeah well and look the look we
almost no one I ever like talked to ever
disagrees even like the most hardcore
libertarian who might like take some a
position of like well you have to invade
us before we can attack you no one
thinks it was unreasonable for Jack
Kennedy to say you can't have nuclear
missiles on in Cuba pointed at us like
you just can't have that without that's
an act of War as far as we're concerned
we have a Monroe Doctrine right that
states that no far away power can come
over here and meddle in our part of the
world we would not accept China
overthrowing the government of Mexico
and installing a pro-chinese government
nope we will go to war with you over
that and like now you're telling me that
like our month Road Doctrine extends all
the way to Russia's borders but they're
not allowed to have a Monroe Doctrine
for the country next to them for their
largest neighbor to just say that like
yo you have and then like people will
come back to me and they'll be like well
Vladimir Putin was interfering in
Ukraine at the same time America was and
it's like yeah that's true but America
interfering in Mexico is not the same
thing as Vladimir Putin interfering in
Mexico right and US intervening in
Ukraine is not the same thing as
Vladimir Putin intervening in Ukraine
it's not just a matter of what's right
and wrong it's just like reality it's
just like you know if you just
hypothetically like let's say you woke
up
and you're the president okay sure
what's the first thing you would do the
the first thing I would do would be to
uh announce that we are no longer
supporting uh that we're no longer
backing Ukraine in this proxy war and
that we're demanding negotiations
whoever my secretary of state I'll send
Scott Horton uh over there to sit down
with Sergey lavrov work out a deal
that's it you guys are locked in a room
until you've come up with an immediate
side I kind of feel like it would happen
very quickly it would happen very
quickly yeah I'm walking back we don't
want to be involved and he's like okay
we're out have a nice day yeah well
that's it and look like I said before
the outline to the deal is so obvious
it's right there in front of everybody
you know it's like it's this is like
it's just a matter of actually getting
people to do it but that'd be number one
then I would pardon uh you know Julian
Assange Edward Snowden Ross Albrecht I'd
pardon I'd probably write an executive
order that repealed every executive
order ever written oh dude you know it'd
be a big it'd be a big day you know what
I would do I would you know the Simpsons
scene where he's in the land of
chocolate and he's running around and
he's like biting everything that would
be me signing pardons
I would I would be I would so uh if it
were me I'd basically pardon any
non-violent offense like almost any not
not like non-property destruction
non-violent like anything like just
possession like a gun possession of
drugs anything like that possession
right as long as they didn't plead down
so if it's like war on drug stuff and
second amendment violations I'm gonna be
going like
she's just signing them into like rubber
stamp on the 100 and then so many
unemployed the bureaucrats
oh yeah oh it would be so much fun yeah
my hand would fall off from signing all
the things well that's what we need but
uh for now we'll go to super chats so if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
click the join us button and become a
member you will get access to our
uncensored members only show which is
going live at about 10 10 p.m it's less
family friendly so you've been warned
but it's a lot of fun and if you if you
join the Discord you can actually submit
questions and call into the show you got
to be a member for at least six months
or sign up at the 25 level we do that to
try and keep out the crazies and the
weirdos who are trying to screw with us
but uh it's probably the best part of
the night in my opinion I love having
the Collins they're a lot of fun
all right here we go normies get out say
Bert coin to the Moon
okay I've been continuing to be our
company cult leader can I just point out
that normies get out it's got an
American flag beanie has been a member
for 37 months
yeah wow it shows you how deep this cold
goes yeah
I'll take away Chris Bertman the
American flag beanie is like the
ultimate beanie it is icon isn't it wow
highest ranking beanie so when you're a
member on the YouTube channel you get
various beanie icons they're different
colors some are like uh Jason Dixon's
got one that's like gold with gems on it
all right Carrie Locke says glad to see
Davey Smith back
each of your thoughts on RFK Junior
running for president as a democrat in
my opinion his voice on the primary
stage will have a similar shock factor I
say Dave Smith in a 2024 presidential
run I don't know I don't know what to
say I mean uh
I think it's good that's about it I mean
like I don't know that much about his
politics other than the covet stuff
um but man yeah I'd be like incredible
to have his voice there and the fact
that he's a candidate like that his last
name is Kennedy and he's not like one of
the like outskirts of the Kennedys he's
not like somebody
yeah you know like I'm like a sixth
cousin or something like he's a real
heir to the Kennedy Legacy I mean like
yeah I think that'd be incred incredible
I'm for all this stuff like when people
float out the idea of Jimmy door running
I think that'd be amazing I think uh
Kennedy Junior running would be amazing
I think like as many more people like
that as you can get in would be great
and maybe even a great libertarian and
uh antipathy or antipathy says regarding
yesterday lefties being stronger I
disagree I believe those committing
violence are the fodder who have nothing
to lose
the left's advantage is promising Fool's
Gold to fools that is true someone else
super chatted that because we did
mention the same topic today I
understand that that it's easy for them
but I actually also kind of disagree to
an extent
let me let me ask your thoughts Dave um
you have a family I do who do you think
is more willing to fight for their
ideology someone with nothing to lose or
someone who needs to save the lives of
their children yeah certainly if if your
family is threatened I think there's
nothing no one willing to fight more
than that however I would say that it's
it's probably true that someone with a
family is a little bit more risk-averse
than someone with that one and so the
what the point I'm making is the threat
to your children is very real to an
extreme degree
but it's fifth generational Warfare so
people are convinced if I stay low and
keep my head down my kids will be safe
when in fact you're condemning them yeah
that's that's how I see it if the far
left is willing to go out and firebomb
things they get let go they're protected
and they'll indict a former president
what future is going to be left behind
for your kids to be safe and I mean so
if your plan is to get an El Salvador
then I'm like oh okay that makes sense
if you were like look I can't fight I
have a family we're moving to El
Salvador cost of living is cheaper
everything's dramatically improving
Bitcoins revolutionizing everything I'd
be like totally get it
but if you were like I want to save
America because my children are going to
live here I'd be like well then why are
you just saying I can't do anything I
have kids and I can't put them at risk
yeah and no one's saying you should do
what the left's doing it's not saying
don't do that but like it's just like
well what are you doing like do do your
best to do something send a message to
Scott Pressler and say like what do you
need buddy because this guy's been
organizing so you know there's one
option
um but also I think they simply put
you know what you do have more kids I
completely agree with that and not even
just to win in the political future it's
just really great to have kids could you
imagine if it's like you know if you're
if you're a guy watching the show and
you're like honey we got to do our part
to save the future so let's go to the
room you know ever see the movie Grease
do it for our country remember that
scene yeah the bomb shelter do it for
our country yeah all right Raymond g
Stanley Jr says Tim it's nice that you
say F them boycott everything but we're
all becoming a bit more polarized you
know I'd rather I'd rather it but do any
of you see the slowing down before it
hits the big fan so this was about uh
the Budweiser thing
is also a brand ambassador for Nike and
I'm just like boycott all of it you have
these these people being like I own a
liquor store and we're getting rid of
Bud Light and I'm like you gotta get rid
of all Anheuser-Busch here's the thing
if every single person who listened to
this show
told their friends
and every single influential person who
has shows who may have who may hear me
say this on their show says the same
thing do not buy anything Anheuser-Busch
it's not just about hurting them in the
sales it's about making them apologize
you want them to get to the point where
they say I'm sorry to you because that
sets a cultural standard yeah and it
scares the next guy like it scares the
next company from doing something like
that where they go oh there's a there's
a real price to be paid for this you
know and this is the point I'm saying
about soy boys when you said but what
are you doing yo people still have
Netflix accounts people still have
Disney accounts people are still buying
Bud Light they're going like ah whatever
red Spotlight who cares it's like that's
it the leftist guy will get fired from
Taco Bell because he can't wear his BLM
mask and then Taco Bell caves and
apologizes yeah but many of you won't
get rid of your Bud Light and if uh in
all fairness a few years ago I was like
I don't know boycotts are stupid now I'm
just like nah you gotta go 10 times
harder you've got a if you have a liquor
store get rid of anything in azer Bush
cancel all your orders and Miller cores
from now on they're like and I'll ask
you this like which are
indistinguishable by the way but I mean
I'm sure someone will like disagree with
me on that but like are
how many people go to the bar and like
or go to a restaurant with their friends
and family and order a Bud Light while
they're having dinner like some people
maybe but not really and would you
really be upset if it was like a high
life instead of a Bud Light like I you
remember that life's way better than Bud
yeah like remember back in cheers
yeah yeah like but you remember you ever
watch cheers and they'd all go up and
they'd be like uh give me a beer Sam and
then Sam would pour him a beer and no
one ever knew what that beer was like
what the brand was it was just like bar
beer I don't know I feel like if you go
into it but like there's there are ipas
there's Guinness or something that's
like a different thing but here's what
local breweries are there like go spend
money there look you don't need to do
this the other thing is if you stop
buying Anheuser-Busch and put all of
that money into doubling your Miller
Coors purchases then the next the next
at the end of the quarter
Anheuser-Busch will report a massive
decline in sales and Miller Coors will
announce a major increase in sales and I
think this happened with Netflix Netflix
saw a mate like they lost like 2 million
subscribers and then it was like serious
problems at Netflix and now they're
recovering and I think what happened was
they had a bunch of weird creepy you
know abusive child exploitative content
conservatives in large numbers started
canceling yeah they panicked and then
started canceling these woke shows
conservative started signing back up now
they're recovering again you have to
vote with your dollars yeah and I've
heard people like uh kind of make the
argument that this is all about like
kind of ESG like Dia die stuff
um and there might be some truth to that
that there's some like Financial
incentive there but there's still
something to their customers buying
their products like that's still
foundationally what their business is
about and if they're losing a huge
portion of their customer base that's
going to negatively impact them and
there does it I I agree with you Tim
where like there probably was a time
where I was like yeah I'd like you like
forget these boycotts it's silly I don't
care about the politics of my you know I
used to say things like which I kind of
disagree I used to say things like look
I don't care if I go into my grocery
store whether the the guy who owns it
voted the way I voted or supported the
war like whatever let's just but when
there's such a like like
like there's such a centralized
um attempt to like indoctrinate to like
infiltrate every inch of the culture
with this at a certain point there's got
to be a cost for that like if if we can
impose some cost on some like I don't
care I'm a Libertarian I don't care what
adults do I don't care what you call
yourself or how you identify I don't
care live your life man if you're
happier that way be happier that way but
when there's this entire effort to like
indoctrinate children and have this
massive push of what is objectively
abnormal behavior and trying to make it
normal it's like at a certain point
there has to be a cost for that so like
maybe it has got to just be some type of
boycott Something Matthew reckham says
Tim why in the ever living Frack did you
make a video about alternatives to Bud
Light and not even mention Samuel Adams
he's literally a founding father who
owns it Sam Adams is not a bad beer but
who I like Sam Adams I don't know is it
not New England Brewer I'd like to think
The Adams Family has kept it in Boston
beerco
Boston beer Miller Coors is one company
for people to understand because I saw
someone mention it's Miller and course
remember the same thing yeah it's Miller
Coors as one company Anheuser-Busch is
another company and they own a whole
bunch of beers so uh sure Sam Adams I
guess but I'm also a bit you know
reluctant because for all I know these
companies are playing all these giant
corporations are on board with this
stuff right so you you basically like
you're checking them by saying don't do
this openly right I personally think you
should buy local I think you should buy
small but if you can't then don't pick
the one that's shoving it in your face
that they are mocking basically all of
your values yeah
all right what do we got let's grab some
more Super chats
Ted 2 says air strike on alaki
guarantees killing action briefers come
to Trump about airstrike on target with
kids present says no boots on ground
instead much more judicious girl gets
caught in crossfire airstrike would be
worse yeah I understand that so that's
the the eight-year-old girl who is also
an American citizen however that Trump
strike that's where the Trump rated
there's a difference there's a
difference in the stories and I would be
open to an inquiry into into both
absolutely but in the story of the
Commando raid it is alleged by people
who are there that this girl died due to
the Commando raid whereas with the
airstrike it is not in dispute at all
well that's look I mean that that is
true although I do think it's pretty
reasonable to assume that what those
people were saying was was correct um
and the girl from what I remember of the
details it was pretty gruesome like bled
out and died it's horrible stuff this is
what war is it's really really horrible
um but this is why at the beginning I
said let's just even focus for like the
sake of argument on just the Anwar alaki
strike because that is admitted that he
was the target of this strike and I'm
sorry sorry if we're to have anything if
we're even going to pretend to be a free
Society then if you're an American
citizen you have to be charged with a
crime you get a lawyer you get a judge
and you get a question by the way you
can try someone who doesn't show up to
their own to their trial they could have
tried on warlocki in America and been
like look he's in Yemen he's refusing to
come back to face trial the prosecutor
can present this evidence a judge can
say yes overwhelming evidence but
there's got to be something this is all
on now though all the stuff you listed
off there these are not only and it's
not just law it's stuff that's supposed
to be you know protected in the most
sacred of
pieces of paper in all human history
yeah like and and and to think that that
it's not just ignored by the government
which makes perfect sense why wouldn't
the government want to ignore the things
that limit them but ignored by the
population you know the people don't
care and when you bring up hey Barack
Obama killed an American by a drone
strike yeah without a without a trial
people look at you like you got a penis
yeah thrown out of your head I think
people don't know I think people forget
about this like we are very aware of
what's going on we tend to follow the
news right but there are tons of people
who don't and they don't say that they'd
be like you're making that up that's
fake news they don't even know look I've
I've had people still say to me you go
like you know they'll be like what was
Obama's biggest Scandal wearing a tan
suit
and you're like dude I mean he had a
secret kill list he armed Al-Qaeda like
he's killed American citizens he started
like five Wars
well he he had Iraq in Afghanistan he he
surged in Afghanistan
um he started Libya Syria Somalia Yemen
drone campaign in Pakistan you know what
you might be right Tim we might be able
to just it's I thought I thought it was
seven inferior and I have friends that
are that like I have friends that you
know that are in the music industry and
stuff and it's like you know they talk
about it uh Afghan well okay no actually
I didn't start didn't start back in the
NFL Syria Libya Yemen Somalia and
Pakistan where Obama those were Obamas
right Obama Started those completely and
we talked about Donald Trump as if he
was so bad like Barack Obama Started
seven wars millions of people died
because of his I think we're clarified
yeah he started five he he resigned over
seven wars he was at War every single
day of his administration and by the way
Trump was that bad it's just compared to
all these other blood-soaked monsters
that you can even make an argument that
they'll go at least he didn't start a
new one now he did continue the worst of
them back well not really I mean look
again we kind of went through this last
time if anything he was like
unhandcuffing the military and the
civilian the rate of Civilian deaths
increased he always talked about ending
him he always talked about pulling them
back and I will give him credit that he
did
um he did negotiate the withdrawal from
Afghanistan he was trying to get our
trip as well yes he was and he was yes
that's true
um but Biden is the one who really
bungled the Afghanistan withdrawal but I
I even give Biden credit for at least
going through with it because there were
Generals who wanted to keep the war
going but then of course he got us right
into this proxy war in Ukraine so all
that I genuinely believe
that Trump does not want these wars
right I think he doesn't care for them
he doesn't understand them he doesn't
want to be involved I just think there
there's no circumstance where you snap
your fingers and they're over and you
look at Afghanistan and what job I think
Joe Biden did this intentionally as a if
you make us pull out this is what you
get kind of thing it's possible or it's
possible that people not quite at
Biden's level but like top brass
military did that almost as a like you
know like for the same reason I agree
with you that I think in Trump's gut
he's like all these wars are stupid and
we shouldn't have fought them I do agree
with that seems to be the case all right
death magnet says gun control is treason
changed my mind actually I think the way
you frame taxes as self-incrimination is
is the most important thing the idea
that you have to incriminate yourself to
the government in a potential crime is
very interesting yeah it's the reason
why there is a fifth amendment it's like
that's that's a pretty basic function of
freedom is that you can't be forced to
incriminate yourself but yeah I don't
think I'm certainly not going to I don't
think anyone here is going to change
your mind about that
I kind of feel like most people don't
want the income tax
I don't know they say they don't but
then well a lot of people want the
benefits I mean a lot of people want
other people's money you know
all right Bobcat says Dave Smith you
talk a lot but will you actually come
out and meet the people if you run or
will you only do pressers like every
other libertarian
what I'm what do you mean meet the
people I'm there's no one more amongst
the people than me I'm a comedian I'm
out constantly all I do is meet people I
was I'm yeah I I don't even know what
that means just do pressers is how the
Libertarians did or whatever I don't
even know I don't even think the
campaign from like yeah I don't even
think that's true about this libertarian
it's the internet anyone
anyone anyone can say stuff well but
also I will say that it's like look if
there is something to be said for the
fact that like it's you know there it's
great to meet people and I'm out all the
time and meet I love meeting like people
who listen to my show and stuff like
that but there is something where we
have this like kind of technology age
now where you can do a show like this
and speak to a much much larger group of
people than you can by just like holding
in events with a couple hundred people
yeah all right uh John deslate says what
if Don Trump gets imprisoned and Don Jr
runs on the platform of his father's
imprisonment gets elected then pardons
his father and become becomes Don
Junior's VP then Trump 2028. uh well
I'll break it down not gonna happen
there is the the when does Baron run yes
well you know about those books right
yeah so as soon as he gets tall enough I
actually I own it but I've never read it
so there is a possibility of like Trump
going to prison and dungeon you're
running but you cannot at the federal
level pardon someone in prison at the
states right so that's just never gonna
happen right correct
it does look it seems so crazy the idea
that Donald Trump would actually be like
convicted of this but then you are like
it's going to be a New York jury yeah
you know exactly because they were like
you know what are the odds you can get
one in Staten Island that's like the
conversation I heard yeah Staten Island
will get him off in a second
trouble be just fine in Staten Island
all right what is this uh uh what we got
here we'll grab some more
Hayden Lewis says hey Tim and gang I
just want to give a shout out to Ian for
always trying to white pill us it gives
me a small sense of hope that we could
fix the U.S
you know you know absolutely I respect
it
I just think it's sometimes it feels
like it's coming from a place of
um naivety you know
when he says things like we got a pardon
Hillary Clinton and I'm like
[Music]
would you Dave pardon Hillary Clinton
absolutely not no I None of the people
up at the very top need to be pardoned
like fauci should be in prison Gavin
Newsom and Cuomo and like all the
lockdown Governors should be in prison
all the high level like war criminals
should be in prison would you put Trump
in prison I sure if I was putting all of
them
let me just say this I wouldn't just put
Donald Trump in prison Donald Trump
should be charged with war crimes and
violations of the Constitution and
international law but I say this about
every president like every president of
my lifetime but that being said I mean
this is all kind of like in fantasy here
but that being said I think if you want
to be white pilled on moving forward I
do think that there's like there's a
certain cutoff line and then other
people like when you're trying to like
almost like overthrow a corrupt
authoritarian regime and instill a new
regime there does have to be forgiveness
and Reconciliation on a mass level and
I'm not talking about Hillary Clinton
I'm talking about like your neighbor
who's reported the lockdowns I'm saying
like regular people who were just really
bad on a lot of these things like
they're you're not going to lock all of
them up can you imagine what the second
Reconstruction Era is going to look like
you know like Trump sending federal
troops to California Washington Oregon
to occupy and replace their governments
well we'll see yeah he didn't do it
during the riots I don't think he's
gonna do it Kyle Bigelow says Dave love
you man been to two SFS sent my folks to
your show in St Louis listen to you and
your people for years what you're
talking about is fresh and fit and
biological red pilling exposing feminism
of all walks yeah I thought it was fresh
and fresh and fit podcast too wait I
didn't I'm sorry I didn't oh right right
right oh the manosphere yeah yeah
he's been to two SFS I don't know skank
Fest I'm sorry
yes that's awesome well I've never heard
anyone call it SFS before but yes okay
got that and then those were the
manosphere yeah look nothing against
those guys I I'm sure like they they all
I probably agree with them on a lot of
stuff you know what I mean it's just I'm
just going off what Clips I see on like
the algorithm it's just delivery I mean
a lot of a lot of the time you can say
these things in a a more measured
fashion it's really about the delivery
because the the the content you can
deliver in a in a way where you're not
going to make I just don't Clips but the
clips look point I probably I probably
like I've seen I don't even know enough
about them to like really have an
opinion or formulate one about them but
like like even like Andrew Tate I
probably agree with a lot of stuff that
he says I just hate promoting Pimp
to young kids I hate that like I'm a
family man and I don't like just as
somebody who's like lived kind of a
degenerate lifestyle for years and then
settled down and got married and had
kids and I'm like it's so much better
and more meaningful and healthier to
like be in this like in a great marriage
I hate anyone promoting to like young
guys who are 22-23 that like you should
aspire to be a Pim please
add some debauchery you're kidding no at
one face let me ask the short one do you
feel like you can realize the value of
the lifestyle I have right now because
you went through that phase in life like
I'm not saying people should go through
it but like do you think I'm being able
to see the difference I mean yes it's
more of a contrast for me and so it
makes it that much clearer but that
being said it's like it's like
I did if you were like paralyzed from
the neck down for like a few months and
then you really appreciated the ability
to walk I still wouldn't recommend
getting paralyzed from the neck you know
what I'm saying so like yeah to me it
probably makes the contrast that much
more clear I still don't recommend any
of that I think it's bad for you it's
bad for your soul it's bad for society
it's like none of it's good but young
men should aspire to like find a good
woman and start a family with him like
that's what you should be aspiring to do
it's much more important than any of
this political stuff that we talk about
which I do love talking about
it says with the results of the
Wisconsin Supreme Court election the
question of Trump versus DeSantis is no
longer one of the one of preference the
GOP nominee has to win Georgia Arizona
and Nevada and guess which three swing
States Trump is the most unpopular in
well there you go
John Casey says didn't Trump ask for two
thousand dollars for Americans and
nothing else and Congress forced the 600
for Americans and millions for Pakistani
gender studies I don't think Trump
should have signed it but I think he
wanted to do something okay but he
signed it into law I just it does irk me
just the constant like excuse making for
Donald Trump look I'm telling he was
framed for treason these charges are
complete nonsense like he says a lot of
good things but he signed it into law
like he did and he had a lot of Leverage
right there that like look Donald Trump
it's just like just run the counter
factual in your head right if all Donald
Trump wanted was two thousand dollar
payments for Americans right and he
didn't want all of the corporate
giveaways in there then Donald Trump
could have vetoed that bill written a
bill himself that said one page two
thousand dollars for all Americans made
a video about it you know is Donald
Trump said I'm sending this bill to
Congress you guys vote for this right
now I'll sign it tonight but none of
these corporate giveaways in there and
just created enormous pressure and
instead he sent all of his people to
Ragdoll the best Congressman Thomas
Massey for being the one guy to oppose
it so don't give me these like constant
excuses for like this he had no choice
he had no he did have a choice he had
all the leverage that's what I say about
like uh when patreon claimed oh if we
don't ban this guy MasterCard will stop
funding transactions and then everyone
gets banned yeah and my response is
I and this actually happened tell
MasterCard that you're going to send 100
million audience members who have lost
access to their favorite podcasts to
them when that happens so when all of
the biggest and most influential people
in the world are asking where their
money is I'll say I don't know ask
MasterCard let's see how you handle that
let's see how your shares handle that
they're there's tremendous leverage yeah
you just have to be a little bit
creative with this stuff and you can
find Solutions it's just but it's like
you said Trump could have done a
national address where he said we are
not giving corporations free money yeah
the money goes to the American people if
Congress push puts forward a bill just
for the American people I'll sign it but
if they try and give their corporate
buddies and the lobbyist free money I'm
not doing it and then everyone will be
rambling at Congress like what's wrong
with you it would have been so easy to
flip it right back around on them and
again there's just so many things like
this like look he was friends with Rand
Paul at least to some degree like they
went golfing and stuff like that and
like why couldn't he have just gone to
Rand Paul and been like like hey Rand
Paul you're a doctor even though he's an
eye doctor but whatever you're a Doctor
Who's a really good epidemiologist
because I can't have this fouchy guy
here all year long so like give me the
best one and let's bring him on board
and I'm firing fauji like he could have
done so many things better and my whole
point about this is like I'm not just
trying to say like he has to be perfect
before we we can support him I'm just
saying that recognize that like the
stakes are so high that like this just
isn't good enough keeping fauci on the
job through all of 2020 that's not good
enough look at what it caused we gotta
like set our standards a little bit
higher and not make excuses for these
politicians no matter who they are your
side or the other side all right
Mandy says 100 of deal is needed to give
Crimea to Russia Putin doesn't want
nukes and people who don't know the
historical structure of that deal need
to shut up the Ukraine U.S expenditures
need to be dealt with when we have new
leaders pretty sure Putin has nukes
well I should I think she's saying
Newton who doesn't want to Nuke doesn't
want to use nukes yeah yeah well no of
course look no one people no one wants
to use nukes when they know that nukes
will be dropped on them if they use them
it's only a move out of desperation the
only in the most desperate circumstances
would have happened but that's what
people who are rooting so hard for
Vladimir Putin to lose and be completely
humiliated and on the verge of being
overthrown need to think about you're
rooting for the one situation where he
might use them monster says you should
get Dave on with Destiny so uh actually
we've been playing the show for a while
and it's just an issue of we are waiting
for the new studio to be built but the
idea for the show is to actually have
like Dave Smith with Destiny and then
have someone moderate and and have that
kind of Crossfire style show that used
to I'd love to yeah I think it would be
enlightening and very enlightening uh
Charlie Kirk says he's always down for
for more shows we did the mock poster of
vosh and Charlie Kirk when they came on
the show and and debated quite a bit so
I debate him to bit Charlie Kirk any of
these guys I love doing stuff like that
so I'm down to like whoever any of these
guys are absolutely happy to talk to you
the issue is we just need the new studio
to be built so we have the space for
because right now we've got like pop
culture crisis and Tim cast IRL the new
studio space is going to have uh
potentially even like three filming
locations inside of it but one large
General space that is multi-purpose for
a bunch of different shows so I just
want to do Clint Russell's poker show
that's what I'm looking for with the
boys I'll debate anyone if you'll book
me on poker with the boys oh bro hands
down I mean I think poker with the boys
could be really unifying yeah in that
having people who normally would argue
not talking about overt politics but
having more like this this is a story I
told earlier today this guy I met at the
poker tables said he thought the j6er
should be executed no joke but at the
same time as I'm like that is the
craziest thing I've ever heard yeah we
were laughing and playing this fun game
together where there were a few there
was one hand where you know he's he's in
hand I'm not he loses and he shows he he
goes to show down with Ace five offsuit
and then he loses and then he's like I
can't win with this hand it's just
really because every single time I get
it as he's saying this I look down at
Ace five off suit and I'm like oh this
is too good if I win and then we go to
Showdown I I go I know I lost and I go
you deserve to win and I flip it over
and he busts out laughing that's the
kind of fun thing that brings people
together despite the fact he said J
sixer should be executed well this is
what kind of why I'm like the essence of
being a Libertarian is hating politics
because it is like if not for politics
we could all just be getting along you
know what I mean but if it's not for
like whose political opinions are one by
the way this poker show is this is going
to be behind the paywall oh oh this is
going to be on YouTube uh maybe I was
gonna say it's gonna happen if it's live
but if I get your Channel
we'll see what happens
um the uh obviously the audience size is
going to be for YouTube but the more fun
maybe Rumble so yeah I gotta really you
know if I start losing chips I'm going
to say all types of stuff yeah but all
right oh man allergies are kicking in
all right everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this share with
your friends head over to timcast.com
click join us in the menu bar become a
member and you'll get access to the
uncensored members only show going live
in about 10 minutes and if you're a
member of for at least six months or the
25 level you can actually submit
questions and potentially call into the
show we screen it we have about three or
four callers every night it's a whole
lot of fun so sign up if you want to ask
questions or just engage with our
community you can follow the show at
timcast IRL you can follow me personally
at timcast Dave you want to shout
anything out uh my podcast part of the
problem uh comic Dave Smith on Twitter
uh comicdavesmith.com for all my my
dates and tours and everything like that
mises caucus libertarian party Ron Paul
mises Institute all that great stuff
uh I'm here clear brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should follow at
timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
you can see work for me and you can see
work from all of our other journalists
including the one and only Chris Bertman
if you want to follow me have to shout
out to our favorite cult leader uh if
you want to follow me personally you can
follow me on Instagram at Hannah
claire.beat and you can follow me on
Twitter at HC Brillo thanks so much okay
I'm sorry one more uh thing which isn't
for me but my uh my brother uh Big Jay
oakerson who's like the funniest
comedian in the universe just put out a
new hour special today uh dog belly on
on YouTube go check that out really
really great wow no way sick uh I am
Phil Levante uh Phil that remains on
Twitter Philip remains official on
Instagram and uh Philip remains on
YouTube yeah
I am definitely gonna watch that uh bjo
Christian special I'm a big fan of big J
he's great yeah he's hilarious
um everyone that's following uh me on
Twitter uh I can't believe I have that
many followers it's great uh yeah at
search.com see you in the after show we
will see all of you over at timcast.com
or in our Discord server thanks for
hanging out